bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat la Haute Assemblée
poursuit ses travaux préparatoires à
l'examen du projet de loi travail après
myiam el comomery mardi c'était hier a
tour des syndicats d'être auditionné et
cela entre deux journées de
manifestation alors cette matinée
d'audition n'a pas appris grand-chose de
nouveau sur les positions des syndicats
tout reste pareil c'est-à-dire que la
CGT et FO reste défavorable à ce projet
de loi avec la CFE csgc elle voit dans
la primuté accordée à l'accord
d'entreprise la possibilité d'un
véritable dumping social d'autre part la
CFDT elle est favorable à la dernière
version du texte avec notamment les
avancées qu'elle voit dans le CPA le
compte personnel d'activité ou encore
l'encadrement des travailleurs détachés
tout de suite donc retour à cette
audition qui s'est tenue hier matin au
Sénat le projet de loi mesdames
messieurs qui compte désormais 102
articles après son passage àassemblée
nationale compose des dispositions
d'importance très inégale en terme
d'impact sur l'organisation du travail
donc je commence par madame peré je vous
laisse la parole puis ensuite nous
feront dans l'ordre que j'ai indiqué
tout à
l'heure bonjour mesdames et messieurs
euh tout d'abord en introduction
quelques éléments de de contexte
rappelez que nous sommes après 3
mois de débat autour de ce projet de loi
travail dans une situation où le
dialogue social à la française a été
bien mise à mal puisque en amont de ce
projet pas de concertation je vais pas
développer hein nous avons les uns et
les autres fortement communiqué sur
l'absence de travail commun avec le
gouvernement
en amont du projet de loi et puis je
tiens aussi à vous rappeler une parodie
de négociation autour du compte
personnel d'activité qui a été bouclé en
quelques semaines qui n'a même pas
débouché sur une quelconque position
commune signée y compris par l'ensemble
du patronat qui avait pourtant écrit le
texte s'ajoute un contexte de
mobilisation sociale extrêmement fort
qui s'amplifie d'ailleurs comme vous
avez pu le voir ces derniers jours donc
plus de 2 mois et demi de contestation
de la majorité des articles qui
composent ce projet de loi et une
opinion publique qui s'exprime àprès de
74 % opposé à ce projet de loi quel que
soit d'ailleurs son évolution y compris
le texte que vous aurez à travailler
vous au Sénat une absence de majorité
parlementaire à l'Assemblée nationale la
semaine dernière et l'utilisation à vœu
de faiblesse de gouvernement en place du
493 ce projet revient maintenant au
Sénat et il vous appartient
évidemment de le modifier les
communication que j'ai entendu ce
weekend à ce propos ne me rassure pas
puisque j'ai comme l'impression que vous
avez l'intention de revenir sur les
quelques avancé qui avait été acquise au
sein de la commission des affaires
sociales de l'Assemblée nationale pour
autant l'ensemble du projet de loi ne
nous convient pas c'est pourquoi nous en
demandons le retrait mais également
c'est pas une position d'immobilisme
l'ouverture de véritables négociations
pour construire un code du travail du
21e siècle j'y reviendrai dans la
dernière partie sur un petit éventail
des propositions que la CGT met au débat
pourquoi elle ne nous convient pas et
bien c'est la philosophie générale de ce
texte que nous contestons elle donne en
effet la primauté absolue à l'accord
d'entreprise sur la sur la loi et sur
les accords de branche c'est ce que nous
appelons les uns et les autres
l'inversion de la Archie des normes et
pour nous serait cela aura pour effet de
faire voler en éclat le socle commun de
protection et de garantie collective
pour les salariés mis en place par le
Code du travail ça veut dire qu'il y
aura demain autant de code de travail
que d'entreprise et que les salariés en
particulier les plus fragiles ceux qui
sont isolés si que ceux qui ne
bénéficient pas de représentants
syndicaux pour les défendre dans les
entreprises seront encore plus
défavorisé c'est évidemment des
questions qui vont concerner leur temps
de travail leur rémunération et en
particulier les heures supplémentaires
qui peuvent être du jour au lendemain
modifié de manière profonde à
l'intérieur d'un enfin d'une entreprise
c'est d'ailleurs par exemple pour ça que
les salariés du transport depuis lundi
soir sont fortement mobilisés ils ont
compris par exemple que en moyenne pour
un chauffeur routier dont la
rémunération est fortement constituée de
supplémentaire cela peut avoir comme
conséquence une perte de jusqu'à 3000 €
annuel sur leur rémunération nous avons
vous le savez beaucoup pesé pour faire
évoluer ce texte et intégrer un certain
nombre de propositions donc je voudrais
essayer de vous dire pourquoi
aujourd'hui à ce stade ce texte nous
convient et nous paraît répondre aux
enjeux qui sont posés à la fois au
modèle économique du pays et à la
situation sociale d'abord la FDT
considère que la situation économique et
sociale du pays est on peut encore la
qualifier de difficile pour des raisons
conjoncturelles qui sont liées à euh aux
événements qui ont suivi la crise
financière et qui ont plongé un certain
nombre de pays dans le notutre dans des
difficultés mais aussi pour des raisons
structurelles euh qui tiennent à un
défaut
d'adaptation de notre modèle économique
et social du côté des entreprises et des
secteurs d'activité éit pas suffisamment
d'innovation pas suffisamment
d'investissement et pas suffisamment de
de souci de la montée en gamme ou de la
montée en qualité des entreprises et des
activités et du côté du modèle social un
modèle qui ne protège plus assez les
travailleurs dans leur ensemble quand je
quand je parle des travailleurs je parle
des salariés mais bien évidemment
au-delà tout le monde connaît ici la
situation du chômage et donc des des des
5 millions de demandeurs d'emploi mais
aussi la PR précarisation grandissante
au marche au marche au March du marché
du travail au March de l'emploi salarié
avec ce qu'on appelle les nouvelles
formes d'emploi où là on voit bien que
notre modèle social ne protège plus du
tout ces ces nouveaux travailleurs donc
une précarité qui s'accroit à la fois
dans le salariat le chômage la montée
desats cours mais aussi au au marge du
salariat et et un modèle social qui n'y
répond pas aujourd'hui on le voit bien
donc nous on veut réformer pas pour le
plaisir de réformer mais réformé pour
permettre aux acteurs de l'entreprise et
quand je dis aux acteurs de l'entreprise
c'est pas l'entreprise nous on considère
que les salariés et leurs représentants
sont des acteurs à part entière
euh donc on veut leur permettre de
trouver des solutions pour à la fois
améliorer la compétitivité des
entreprises mais aussi apporter du
progrès social au plus près des acteurs
de leurs besoins et et et de leurs
besoins de de protection notamment et
donc nous on a la conviction que c'est
le dialogue social qui peut porter ces
réformes profondes dont notre pays a
besoin c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous considérons qu'aujourd'hui ce texte
répond à ces objectifs d'abord du point
de vue du dialogue social la nouvelle
articulation qui est proposée entre la
loi la la branche et l'entreprise nous
semble pertinente d'abord je je vais pas
m'amuser à contredire point par point ce
qui a été dit juste avant moi mais et à
l'évidence on sait tous qu'il n'y a pas
il n'y aura pas un code du travail par
entreprise avec cette loi mais qu'il y a
bien un code du travail qui est maintenu
qui continue de protégé et qui contient
notamment deux éléments extrêmement
importants de protection des salariés
d'abord un certain nombre de règles qui
demeurent et qui sont les mêmes pour
tout le monde les 35 he par exemple le
déclenchement des heures supplémentaires
au-delà de C des 35 he par exemple bon
mais il y a aussi dans ce code du
travail un droit supplétif qui euh qui
qui qui demeure et qui demeure la CFDT
il a beaucoup œuvré à droit constant
c'est-à-dire que les règles de ce qui
s'applique en l'absence d'accord dans
les branches et dans les entreprises ce
sont les règles du Code du travail
aujourd'hui donc il est faux par exemple
de prétendre comme on le fait ces
jours-ci que les routiers vont devoir
voir leurs heures supplémentaire passer
de 25 % à 10 % de rémunération puisque
ça ne serait possible que s'il y avait
des organisations syndicales
représentant plus de la moitié des
salariés ou plus de la moitié des
salariés eux-mêmes qui en décident de
cette façon et je n'imagine pas que
c'est les gens seraient assez stupid
pour le faire et en tout cas pour le
faire sans contrepartie cette loi n'est
pas une loi de de progrès social le
gouvernement fait preuve aujourd'hui
d'autoritarisme malgré l'expression de
milliers de de salariés et de nombreux
syndicat dans la rue depuis plusieurs
mois malgré le le refus de plus de 70 %
des Français d'accorder leur faveur à
cette à cette loi et malgré un manque de
de de majorité donc il utilise le le 49
3 et pour nous ça représente
véritablement un dénis de de
démocratie pour pour info il y a pas de
de déconnexion entre euh cette loi
travail et les politiques économiques
globales que mène ce gouvernement euh je
rappelle quand même que 100 milliards
d'exonération en 3 ans ont été mises en
place en faveur des des entreprises pour
très peu de de de résultat et que depuis
euh euh ce mandat euh ce dernier mandat
et bien
euh ce ce ce projet de de loi s'inscrit
euh dans une logique libérale loi de
sécurisation de l'emploi qui prévoyait
déjà leur mise en cause du contrat de
travail en 2013 la loi sur le dialogue
social qui remets en cause Laib les
possibilités de représentation des
salariés en l'entreprise la loi pour la
croissance et l'activité qui a instauré
le travail dominical et qui a réformé
les prunoms de la façon dont on sait
donc euh il est clair que pour pour nous
les questions sociales constituent pour
ce gouvernement de véritables variables
d'ajustement avec toujours plus de de
flexibilité pour les salariés de ce
point de vue aucune analyse aucune étude
démontre que la déréglementation rend
plus compétitive et favorise les
créations d'emplois même l'OCDE dit
qu'on ne peut pas conclure à ça
alors l'objectif donné au code du
travail aujourd'hui on le connaît tous
hein c'était bien de rééquilibrer dans
le cadre du lien de subordination les
parties les parties au contrat donc les
parties faibles parties forte et le code
du travail n'avait pas n'a pas pour
objectif aujourd'hui de de créer des
emplois ou même de sécuriser les
employeurs nous étions nous favorbl
effectivement pour réformer le code du
travail parce qu'aujourd'hui le code du
travail ne ne convient à personne et que
effectivement on a besoin de l'adapter
hein par rapport à à à l'avenir euh à
l'évolution du monde du travail la
numérisation l'ubérisation et de ce
point de vue-là effectivement il y a
lieu à mettre en place de véritables
négociation euh moi enfin nous sommes de
ceux qui partageons l'idée que le droit
du travail ne peut pas être quelque
chose de de de de simple la nature ayant
horreur du vide si dorénant dorénavant
on allège le le le code du du travail et
bien on va mettre de côté des dizaines
d'années de jurisprudence et cetera et
on va aller droit vers vers une
amplification du contentieux nous étions
nous favorables euh pour réformer le
code du travail donner plus de de
lisibilité plus d'accessibilité
notamment pour euh les chefs
d'entreprise des des des des PME
euh mais euh avec deux impératifs comme
je disais donc à droit constant hein et
avec la le respect de la hiérarchie des
normes mais on sait très bien que euh ça
n'a pas été du tout euh respecté sur la
question de de la méthode effectivement
là aussi euh
euh ça pose quand même quelques
problèmes nous avons pris connaissance
de l'intégralité du du texte après la
presse et donc ça pose un problème de
force de forme par rapport donc au
respect euh de l'article L1 du du Code
du travail même si aujourd'hui on a
constaté que le juge a tranché qu'il ne
ressort pas donc de son office de
s'imisser dans le processus de vote
d'une loi devant le le Parlement pour
aut ant on voit bien que le juge n'a n'a
pas du tout remis en cause le fond de la
contestation que nous portions et donc
nous nous donnons le le le droit de
poursuivre sur le plan juridique notre
notre action donc effectivement pour
nous ça a été à la connaissance de de de
de cette présentation de de projet de
loi une véritable rupture dans dans dans
le mode de des relations sociales avec
la remise en cause d'un principe
républicain qui met en place l'égalité
de droit et l'égalité de traitement que
vous soyez aujourd'hui salarié d'une TPE
de TR trois salariés ou que vous
fassiez partie d'une grande entreprise
vous avez aujourd'hui les mêmes droits
des droits qui sont couverts par la
convention collective ou l'accord de de
branche aujourd'hui ce projet de loi
vise donc à la primauté de l'accord
d'entreprise avec la mise en place
incontestable de l'inversion de la
hiérarchie des normes qui va faire
sauter
le verrou de la branche et créer
inévitablement un dumping social on voit
tout à fait le cas notamment sur la la
question de la majoration des heures
supplémentaires qui donnera la
possibilité aux entreprises de les
rémunérer à 10
% minimum donc euh c'est vraiment cette
articulation euh une remise en cause
d'un principe républicain avec un code
du travail qui va être complètement
allégé avec un ordre public dont on ne
sait pas réellement ce qui va
représenter l'ordre public social on en
parle plus l'ordre public absolu on en
parle plus du tout donc quelque chose de
très flou qui va permettre donc de
renvoyer une grande parti des droits à à
la négociation d'entreprise pour
soi-disant adapter les entreprises à la
compétitivité et la création d'emplois
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
je pense qu'il faut rappeler que
préalablement à ce projet de loi il y a
eu un certain nombre de
concertations puisque nous avons tous eu
l'occasion d'être entendu à l'occasion
de au sujet de différents rapports
corbrexel
balinter Césaro Metling terrasse et je
suis sûr que je do j'en oubli
quelques-uns tous les syndicats
j'imagine j'en suis sûr ont contribuer
lors de ces rapports contribuer de façon
écrite pour notre re part nous avons sur
bon nombre d'entre eux indiqué les
raisons pour lesquelles nous n'étions
pas favorables aux suggestions qui était
faite même si c'est le cas de du rapport
qu' brexel nous partageions l'objectif
qui était de enrichir et favoriser et
développer le dialogue social parce que
nous pensons nous effectivement que
c'est par ce moyenl qu'on peut améliorer
la vie dans les entreprises et pourquoi
pas même la compétitivité de notre pays
mais nous ne partagions
pas ce qui commencait à à s'esquisser
dans ce rapport c'est se renvoie à la
négociation dans l'entreprise
et affaiblissement de la
branche et par voie de conséquence ce
qu'on qualifie aujourd'hui parfois
peut-être un peu rapidement d'inversant
de la hiérarchie des normes et dès le
début nous avons indiqué que nous
n'étions pas favorables avec ce
dispositif parce que ça consiste à
envoyer la négociation dans l'endroit où
les syndicats sont les plus faibles où
les salariés sont les moins bien
représenté et par ailleurs avec des
forts risques de dumping social alors en
ce mot il faut lui mettre des guillemets
parce que on est en France quand même on
est pas mais c'est néanmoins du dumping
social quand on laisse l'opportunité à
chacune des entreprises d'adapter
finement de le coût du travail et de
revenir sur des normes soit définies par
la loi soit défini par la négociation de
branch et à cette occasion il est
intéressant de noter que les entreprises
elles-mêmes sont très réticentes et très
frileuses avec cette nouvelle
possibilité de négocier dans
l'entreprise des choses telles que la
rémunération des heures supplémentaires
les collègues ont tous rappelé le risque
de dumping social de concurrence entre
les entreprises sur le social c'est
dangereux alors le le nouveau texte
soumis enfin le texte 493 prévoit entre
autres cette possibilité aux branches de
faire un rapport sur l'état des accords
d'entreprise et les effets que ça peut
avoir justement sur les distorsions de
concurrence les entreprises et faire des
recommandations c'est un premier pas
mais pour nous c'est
insuffisant je veux pas employer le
terme de droit de veto mais je le redis
c'est quand même essentiel pour nous que
la branche joue pleinement son rôle de
de régulateur et d'accompag agnement des
entreprises on voit il y a beaucoup de
choses qui sont prévues dans le projet
de loi sur l'accompagnement des des TPE
la branche a un rôle essentiel à jouer
en la matière et ça doit passer par ce
cadrage de la négociation entreprise
c'est à la branche de dire quel thème on
permet à la négociation entreprise et
dans quel cadre en aucun cas ça veut
dire ne pas négocier enentreprise je le
redis c'est une nouvelle possibilité de
négociation qui mérite d'exister qui
mérite d'être développé mais mais aussi
d'être du coup cadré par la
branche sur euh quand j'ai dit ça euh je
reviens aussi euh aux dispositions
supplétives qui prévoi pour certaines
d'entre elles euh le pouvoir unilatéral
de
l'employeur dans la même logique que je
viens de l'expliquer attention à ça
attention à ça euh laissons à la branche
le rôle de régulateur si dans le
supplétif on renvoie au pouvoir un
atéral pardon de l'employeur on met en
cause à la fois la négociation
l'entreprise qu'on veut qu'on veut
développer et à la fois le rôle de
régulateur de de la branche c'est
contreproductif du coup dans certaines
dispositions plus suppleétives de
renvoyer au pouvoir unilatéral de
l'employeur merci bien mesdames
messieurs je vais passer la parole
évidemment aux trois rapporteurs mais je
voudrais dire aux collègues qui souhait
intervenir de lever le doigt bien comme
il faut et comme je vous tourne le dos
c'est évidment
Laurent et gersand qui sont sur votre
droite qui prendront les noms et qui me
les passeront
ensuite donc Monsieur Le Moine la
parole merci monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup aux uns et aux autres pour ses
exposé très clair précis sur les
positions par rapport au textees et aux
différentes mesures et vous êtes chacun
rentrer effectivement dans le détail
au-delà du débat public sur des mesures
qui parfois sont techniques mais
d'importance effectivement pour la vie
quotidienne et des salariés et des
entreprises on a noté d'ailleurs un
certain nombre de de suggestions ou de
perches que vous AZ étendu et on
regardera ça naturellement avec les
corrapporteurs de façon attentive parce
que il y a sûrement effectivement
encore des des articles à peaufiner à
polir et et naturellement à côté des des
mesures qui ont été travaillées déjà par
le Sénat dans le cadre de position de
loi qui
vraisemblablement seront également mis
en discussion dans le cadre de de
l'examen du projet de loi
ici alors une une remarque une
question
cette comment dire articulation nouvelle
entre branch
entreprisees loi ordre public finalement
elle a été
décrite par certains comme
révolutionnaire mais est-ce qu'au
contraire on est on n pas juste 15 ans
de retard je m'explique en 2001 une
position commune avait été signée par
une grande partie des personnes enfin
des organisations représentées à la
tribune euh je donne acte à la CGT de sa
constance euh mais du coup cette
position commune de 2001 déjà je l'ai
reprise je l'ai sous les yeux précisit
qu'effectivement
euh la branche jouait je un rôle
structurant de solidarité d'encadrement
d'impulsion mais tout de suite il étaé
ajouté après que la négociation
d'entreprise permet de trouver de mettre
en œuvre des solution prenant
directement en compte les
caractéristiques et les besoins de
chaque entreprise et de ses salariés
donc on voit bien qu'il y a là en fait
un mouvement qui d'ailleurs n'était pas
seulement amorcé à ce moment-là qui
était en germe depuis une vingtaine
d'années et qu'on est aujourd'hui dans
la poursuite de ce cycle et que en
réalité il s'agit tout simplement
effectivement d'essayer de donner un un
contenu encore plus dense à la
négociation
euh y compris à l'échelon décentralisé
mais que ça ne remet pas en cause pour
autant le fait que les autres échelons
continuent à jouer un rôle et et un rôle
important alors
j'aurais une question en particulier
sur
le comment dire la la façon là de
valider euh les accords avec le
changement de règles de majorité
effectivement puisqu'on passe du système
à 30 % pour conclure un accord sauf
opposition de 50 % à la nécessité
d'avoir un 50 % positif je dirais
d'adhésion dès le départ euh est-ce
queil y a pas le risque euh de voir en
fait peu d'accords être conclus cont
tenu de cette nouvelle barre euh je
citerai pr pour mémoire le fait que par
exemple l'État lui-même négociant dans
le cadre de la fonction publique
l'accord de 2015 on est arrivé à 49 %.
et de façon unilatérale du coup l'état
voilà a mise en application l'accord
mais on était à 49 % pas
50 et donc ne faudrait-il pas imaginer
un cheminement progressif où
effectivement le 50 % reste un objectif
et un
objectif à atignable il s'agit pas de le
renvoyer au Caland grec mais donc avoir
une montée en puissance pour imaginer
une étape intermédiaire à 40 % puis
l'entrée en vigueur du du 50 % sachant
que là aussi je me réfère à à cette
position commune de 2001 qui à l'époque
sur les majorités précisait bien qu'il y
avait deux options elle disait soit a
soit B a c'était 50 % d'adhésion positif
et le B c'était opposition de 50 % donc
je veux dire cette notion de majorité
voilà elle peut se elle peut se voir de
plusieurs façons sans remettre en cause
fondamentalement les droit des salariés
que vous
représentez et la démocratie sociale a
ses propres règles je crois que si on
mettait tout en comparaison avec la
démocratie politique ça voudrait dire
aussi
peut-être arriver un certain nombre de
révision parce que si on pousse la si on
pousse totalement le parallélisme
démocratie représentative politique et
sociale
euh bon nous euh il y a pas de monopole
de présentation d'un parti sinon je
seraai pas ici j'étais élu en
indépendant donc c'est pour ça qu'il y a
des limites et et que finalement la
règle de majorité elle pourrait aussi
tout à
fait être adaptée mais pour donner sa
chance au produit je dirais voilà donc
c'est ma question sur sur ce niveau de
validité des accords et puis peut-être
question subsidiaire plus courte euh on
a bien senti l'attachement aux branches
euh les commissions paritaires qui
deviennent
permanentes aussi euh devrait se mettre
en condition de
pouvoir euh agir et travailler de façon
peut-être plus efficiente encore je
m'explique parce que par exemple elles
ont un rôle d'ors et déjà pour une sorte
de contrôle de l'égalité des accords qui
ont été signés avec des IRP non mandatés
on voit bien que le système est pas
totalement satisfaisant
parce que les réunions de ces
commissions ne sont pas forcément si
fréquentes et moi je me demande si le
législateur doit pas intervenir pour
préciser que c'est pas une fois par an
qu'elle se retrouve au minimum mais
peut-être trois ou quatre fois pour
vraiment enclencher le rythme et faire
en sorte que ce niveau-là également et
son mot à dire voilà merci Monsieur
gabouti oui mesdames
messieurs on peut pas revenir sur sur
tous les points mais on a eu l'occasion
d'en discuter dans dans des
auditions avec les uns et les autres qui
sont d'ailleurs pas pas pas terminés on
voit bien que un des point
sensible du texte
c'est l'équilibre entre effectivement
les trois niveaux code du travail accord
de branche et et et accord
d'entreprise en ce qui concerne plus
particulièrement les PME et les TPE
euh c'est vrai que l'accord de branche
et la branche effectivement le lieu
principal de de de négociation plus que
l'entreprise puisque dans l'entreprise
dans la grande partie des TPE et des PME
il n'y a pas de représentation syndicale
d'où l'importance du niveau branche
euh partant de ce constat et sachant que
on est sur un problème de curseur parce
que je pense que personne ne remet en
cause un rôle régulateur de la branche
simplement on lui donne un peu plus ou
un peu moins d'importance mais c'est pas
c'est c'est loin d'être c'est loin
d'être
négligeable dans dans ce alors on peut
inventer tous les systèmes c'est-à-dire
la loi fixe la loi fixe effectivement
oui j'ai bien compris le mendatement je
n'oublie pas je vais vous en dire un mot
d'ailleurs
euh non c'estoui au cas où j'aurais une
paire de mémoire merci Madame brick
donc non non non
non donc si vous voulez c'est il y a
plusieurs formules possibles
c'est-à-dire c'est le code qui fixe ce
qui se traite au niveau de l'entreprise
au niveau de la branche ù on est dans un
système supplétif ou effectivement on
peut avoir une décentralisation en
cascade ce qui été évoqué par l'un
d'entre vous je crois que c'est vous
monsieur Jardon de dire bah si on laisse
à la branche la liberté de fixer une
partie de ce qu'elle renvoie
éventuellement lac entreprise donc il
n'y a pas un modèle un modèle unique et
peut-être d'ailleurs que le modèle que
on va choisir dans les mois à venir ne
sera peut-être pas le bon modèle
définitif un modèle c'est fait pour
c'est fait pour évoluer il faut pas
figer les choses éternellement
je je reviens à deux deux questions sur
ces problèmes d'accord d'entreprise
particulièrement pour les PME et les TPE
euh vous invoquez souvent le le le
principe de de démocratie euh
seriez-vous favorable ce qu'il n'y a pas
euh de syndicat donc ce qui est le cas
dans beaucoup de PME et TPE seriez-vous
favorable à ce que des des accords
d'entreprise puissent être conclus par
les instances représentativ du du
personnel notamment les les délégués du
personnel où il y a quand même pas mal
de délégués du personnel même lorsqu'il
n'y a pas délégué syndical délégués du
personnel qui sont délégués syndical
sont parfois eux-mêmes syndiqués hein
les situations sont pas toujours aussi
euh euh je dirais classique qu'on qu'on
peut l'imaginer euh parce que ce sont
des représentants qui sont élus qui déjà
peuvent signer certains accords dans
certains domaines et qui semblent dans
ce type de structure tout aussi légitime
que des représentants syndicaux 2e 2e
question
euh sur les PME et les TPE euh
euh je veux dire aujourd'hui vous avez
nécessairement et vous le savez c'est la
réalité je dis pas qu'il faut
l'approuver vous avez dans ces
structures des accords de fait
c'est-à-dire des accords non
formalisés qui ne respecte pas le cadre
légal et qui dont le fonctionnement est
lié euh je dirais à la à la bonne
volonté à une bonne entente
entre direction et et et salariés mais
avec une
insécurité juridique certaine donc on ne
peut pas encourager ce type de
chos ne pensez-vous pas que sur ces
types de structure passer
obligatoirement alors qu'on a le choix
oui mais passer obligatoirement par le
mandatement madame brick euh je dirais
conduisent à maintenir des
situations d'insécurité dans ce type de
structure car il me semble que dans des
petites entreprises voire les très
petites entreprises ni les dirigeants
d'entreprise ni les salariés ne
souhaitent un une procédure forcément de
mandatement euh donc je m'arrête sur ce
sujet et je passe à un sujet tout à fait
différent avec une question relativement
courte pour vous demander ce que vous
pensez du nouveau dispositif de santé au
travail avec l'abandon du certificat
d'aptitude et les responsabilités qui
pourrant découler euh pour la
l'entreprise ou pour le salarié en cas
d'inadaptation je dirais du poste de
travail à certaines certains
aspects physique ou de santé du salarié
et de la définition non précisée
d'ailleurs dans le texte des salariés
qui mériterait un suivi renforcé donc
quelles sont vos positions je dirais
sur les catégories et le le le le mode
de je dirais de de de de d'appréciation
et de sélection je pas employer ce terme
parce qu'il est pas c'est pas tout à
fait le bon terme mais je dirais des des
salariés qui méritent ce suivi
renforcé merci je passe la parole à
Monsieur
fuissier c'est bon c'est bon merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les représentants des
organisations syndical représentant les
salariés en ce qui me concerne j'ai
travaillé sur des sujets très
particulier puisqu'il s'agit du CPA de
la formation professionnelle et
particulièrement de
l'apprentissage alors le CPA aujourd'hui
tel que je le ressens euh ressenti qui a
été amplifié par hier il y avait Madame
le Ministre du travail à votre place qui
m'a donné quelques son point de vue et
ses éclaircissements alors étant en
quelque sorte le défenseur et promoteur
de la loi je je pense que ces
orientations sont maintenant très
claires à mon esprit parce qu'il s'agit
non pas d'un compte mais pour moi d'un
regroupement de trois comptes tel que
vous l'avez déjà bien exprimé et ces
trois comptes vivant chacun leur vie et
capitalisant sur un portage par le
salarié jusque là bon c'est clair ça ce
cette cet avantage alors le compte
personnel de formation en est à ses
balbuement puisqu'il fonctionne déjà par
contre le C3P le compte personnel de
prévention de la pénibilité euh je pense
qu'il nécessite quand même un travail
important parce qu'aujourd'hui on est
quand même dans beaucoup d'incertitude
et il faut en quelque sorte affiner par
des négociations et regarder comment sa
mise en œuvre pourra euh s'installer
d'une manière équitable et puis alors le
le dernier compte le compte d'engagement
citoyen je vous avoue très objectivement
que j'ai du mal à en définir le contour
exa dans l'état actuel de la loi là
aussi si on comprend bien le service
civique la réserve militaire la réserve
communale de sécurité civile la réserve
sanitaire le maître d'apprentissage
cétait demandeur pourquoi pas le
bénévola associatif peut également
retenu mais enfin le contour du
bénévolat associatif vous savez comme
moi c'est pas d'une évidence totale la
valeur ajoutée qui va amener un
engagement bénévole peut-être aussi
contestable c'est pas
forcément un gage d'intérêt général
alors je crois que ce ce qui manque à
mon sens de mon point de vue personnel
je parlerai pas d'un d'un statut du
travailleur je parlerai d'un statut
d'actif de manière qu'on considère à la
fois quel que soit le salarié à partir
du moment où il est signataire d'un
contrat d'apprentissage dès l'âge de 15
ans ce qui est normal parce qu'il rentre
dans le monde là pour le coup du travail
et le compte actuellement est clos au
décès de la personne alors pour moi il y
a une étape là qui à mon avis il
faudrait pas zapé comme on dit en
langage moderne c'est le passage à la
retraite parce que traditionnellement
qu'est-ce qui se passe quand un salarié
passe à la retraite il y a une
liquidation des droits et l'ouverture de
nouveaux droits c'est quand même pas un
passage à nedin ou alors peut-être que
cela veut dire qu'on considère aussi que
compteenu on le sait tous des salariés
pauvres aujourd'hui quand ils
arrivveront à la retraite est-ce que
c'est l'occasion de leur ouvrir un
possibilité d'avoir des ressources
complémentaires en reprenant un emploi
ça aussi on peut aussi se poser la
question
la question on est certain à se la poser
en se disant quelle sera la position à
prendre sans préjuger bien entendu du
débat alors c'est à mon sens ça
nécessite une évolution alors le statut
d'actif pour moi c'est le statut c'est
là-dessus qu'il faut quand même
travailler si on veut
appliquer CPA parce que un statut
d'actif ça donne des droits et des
devoirs pour l'actif et des droits et
des devoirs pour le l'employeur et je
crois que c'est cette cette règle du jeu
qui manque on a l'outil mais quelque
part et ben évidemment où le B blesse et
où c'est difficile c'est d'arriver par
la négociation qui évidemment ne peut
n'a pas pu avoir lieu tant que le
dispositif n'existait pas mais qui je
crois aujourd'hui ça peut être une
avancée pour tout le monde si on prend
ce sujet à bras le cœur et on prend la
peine de d'établir une vraie négociation
et puis la difficulté aussi qui
aujourd'hui il me semble euh sur la
formation professionnelle et
l'apprentissage c'est que on avait eu
une annonce du gouvernement qui allait
avoir un volet sur l'apprentissage et ce
volet malheureusement ne figure pas en
ce qui me concerne parce que c'était
c'est ce que j'appelais de mes vœux dans
le texte de la loi alors vous doutez qui
étant mobilisé le Sénat la commission
par le BIA de la commission des affaires
sociales et la commission spécialisée
plus la délégation des entreprises va
amener un certain nombre d'amendements
et je souhaiterais par contre là votre
implication dans le sujet de
l'Apprentissage et de la Formation
Professionnelle tel qu'on le voit on a
fait des travaux aussi en relation avec
l'Allemagne tel qu'on le voit en
Allemagne je dis pas calquer le système
allemand en France mais que notre
système puisse se baser sur une
implication qui considère que la
formation professionnelle initiale qu
l'apprentissage doit être une voie de
réussite je vous
remercie bien je vous laisse répondre au
rapporteur dans le même ordre m
p
bon je vais pas faire des réponses à
chaque question parce que je voudrais
déjà dans un premier temps dire que
toutes vos questions de fond que vous
posez démontrent quand même qu'on est
face à un projet de loi qui pose plus de
questions qu'il n'amène de réponse et
que ça devrait non mais ça devrait nous
interroger 5000 amendements à
l'Assemblée nationale plus de
300 modifiant le texte vous allez je
suppose à partir partir de de maintenant
commencer aussi à le modifier
profondément ça montre quand même que ce
projet de loi est pour le moins inabouti
et je crois que cela plaide sur la
proposition que nous faisons de manière
unitaire avec un certain nombre
d'organisations de jeunesse et
d'organisations syndicales de prendre le
temps de d'un véritable dialogue social
et de revenir au fond sur chacune des
questions que vous
posez la la la première je crois que
vous avez posé à à plusieurs voix
concerne la question de la version de la
hiérarchie des normes alors je suis
d'accord avec vous sur un point au moins
la CGT à de la constance et
effectivement en 2001 nous n'avions pas
signé l'accord parce que nous ne sommes
nous sommes en désaccord profond avec la
vision du dialogue soci soci qui est en
train de se mettre en place avec ce
projet de loi très clairement nous
sommes en désaccord profond total sur
cette question du dialogue social et du
rapport entre la loi la convention
collective et les branches et l'accord
d'entreprise donc c'est clairement
effectivement un désaccord majeur que
nous
avons ce ce je je précise d'ailleurs que
ce
projet qui
est qui qui apparaît dans le dans le
projet de loi actuel il est pas
déconnecté d'une politique européenne
que nous remettons en cause sur le sujet
et avec nous d'autres syndicalistes
européens qui par exemple en Allemagne
en Italie en Espagne au Portugal nous
ont fait parvenir leur soutien parce que
il considèrent que justement la France
est un des derniers remparts contre la
modification profonde du dialogue social
et du rapport employeur salarié qui est
en train de se mettre en place
notre la possibilité que nous ayons
encore de pouvoir protéger le salariat
par la loi c'est quelque chose qui
n'existe pas dans un certain nombre de
pays et que des syndicalistes européens
nous
envit sur la question donc de l'accord
d'entreprise et et la question du de
l'accord
majoritaire je pense que quand nous
l'avons construit avec un certain nombre
d'organisations syndicales dans la
négociation dans la concertation il y
avait tout à fait la possibilité d'aller
très rapidement à la question d'une
représentativité à 50 % permettant de
signer un accord majoritaire ce qui
s'est passé entre 2001 et aujourd'hui
c'est un changement
majeur du capitalisme qui qui préfigure
enfin qui qui dans notre pays c'est la
campagne du grand patronat du meddeef
sur la baisse incessante du coût du
travail lié à la compétitivité à la
financiérisation de l'économie et à
partir de là si ce dogme est érigé il
n'y a plus la possibilité d'entrer dans
le cadre de négociation qu'elle soit de
branche ou d'entreprise qui apporte un
mieux au salariés puisque l'objectif
c'est de créer justement du dumping
social en faisant baisser coûte que
coûte le coût du travail jusqu'à au
niveau peut-être d'un salarié SRI
lancain alors même d'ailleurs que
l'essentiel du marché de notre industrie
notre économie est concentré sur les
frontières de l'Union européenne j'en
dis pas plus donc il n'est
pas impossible à notre égard de faire
vivre dès maintenant l'accord à 50 % si
on travaille autrement sur la conception
de ce qui doit primer dans ce qui doit
faire société deain c'est pas l'argent
pour nous c'est le progrès social et
l'humain deuxème point c'est la question
de la démocratie sociale et de la
citoyenneté l'entreprise pourquoi il y a
des problèmes aujourd'hui dans la
représentation des salariés dans
l'entreprise mais parce que il n'y a pas
assez de protection des IRP il y a pas
assez de protection des syndiqués qui
osent syndiquer faire de l'action
parce qu'il y a une montée de la
criminalisation de de l'activité
syndicale parce qu'il y a une montée de
de salariés qui ont peur de se syndiquer
de s'affirmer parce qu'il y a une montée
de la précarité dans le salariat et que
la précarité n'aine pas à s'engager en
matière de syndicalisme et de
citoyenneté à l'entreprise donc faisons
évoluer c'est la reconnaissance du
syndicalise dans l'entreprise et je
pense que vous verrez y compris en
organisant des élections en faisant en
sorte que les élections se passent bien
que les protocoles soit bien rempli que
les employeurs jouent leur jeu le jeu
là-dessus il y a plein de choses à dire
il y a des vous pouvez aller voir la DGT
publie un site très intéressant sur les
dysfonctionnements en matière d'élection
professionnelles avec tout ça je pense
qu'on arrivera très facilement à avoir
des organisations syndicales qui sont en
capacité de jouer leur rôle qu'il il y
aura une montée très forte du taux de
syndicalisation de la représentativité
des syndicats euh on avait fait une
proposition je fais le lien avec une de
vos questions concernant plutôt les
petites et les moyennes entreprises nous
on n'est pas favorable au mandatement on
pense que c'est euh inefficace et euh y
compris que ça va complexifier euh les
rapports les relations des salariés dans
l'entreprise par contre dans la
négociation qui a échoué l'an dernier en
janvier 2015 sur préfiguratrice pardon à
la loi repsamen donc la négociation sur
la démoc soci nous av fait des
propositions des propositions qui
s'appuyent notamment sur des accords qui
on été signés compris qui ont été signés
par la CGT parce que quand il y a de
bons accords la CGT les signes des
accords entre l'UPA et donc les
organisations syndicales sur la question
des cpira et donc il y a la possibilité
de créer des commissions locales
justement au niveau territorial pour
travailler encore mieux d'ailleurs la
GPECT parce que nous y sommes favorables
et qu'on est de vrais élus représentants
des salariés des entreprises petites et
moyennes y compris en travaillant sur la
notion de Bass réseau de bassin ou
réseau de branche et qui puisse
réellement représenter les salariés ça
c'est des propositions me semble-t-il
qui sont de nature à améliorer le
dialogue social dans l'entreprise le
patronat n'en a pas voulu dans la
négociation en démocratie sociale la loi
ne l'a pas repris c'est bien dommage
peut-être que c'est là-dessus qu'il
faudrait ouvrir le débat quelques
éléments sur la médecine du travail je
vais pas rentrer dans les détails nous
sommes pas favorables évidemment en ce
moment à la proposition enfin en ce
moment à l'heure actuelle de la du
projet de loi sur les propositions à la
fois de la question du certificat
d'aptitude et sur la sélection parce que
je pense qu'il faut bien dire ça sur la
sélection des pseudo salariés à risque
par contre nous avons porté un certain
nombre de propositions qui d'ailleurs
devait être prise en amont du projet de
loi el comomery par la la ministre n
l'avait assuré elle-même qui était issue
du travail concerté long approfondi à
l'issue d'un avis du C à partir du
travail du COCT hein qui avait fait
l'unanimité syndicale et qui concernait
le Plan Santé Travail quelques éléments
là-dessus parce que vous voyez que le
dossier médecine du travail il est vous
pouvez jeter tous les articles et
reconstruire un paragraphe entier sur
une autre conception de la Santé au
Travail et de la santé public pour nous
il y a maintenant et tous les
spécialistes le le reconnaissent il y a
un triptique Santé Travail environnement
la majorité des problèmes de santé
aujourd'hui y compris de santé qui sont
extrêmement coûteuse pour notre système
de sécurité sociale proviennent à la
fois du
travail de la de la
mauvaise hygiène de vie et de des
questions de pollution et
d'environnement donc quand est-ce qu'on
travaille ce triyptique ensemble Santé
Travail environnement nous on appelle ça
à la CGT une proposition de
développement humain durable ça va
au-delà du développement euh durable et
ça passe par quelques points que je vais
vous rappelez la question de la
prévention systématique qui
euh précède ou plutôt qui est même
contradictoire avec ce qu'on la
politique actuelle de gestion des
risques et de
réparation après c'està dire que voyez
la question du compte personnel de
pénbilité retraite pour nous c'est un
pisaler parce qu'on devrait pouvoir un
jour le faire disparaître si on avait
une vraie politique de prévention et non
pas de gestion y compris gestion
économique des risques qu'on fait porter
sur l'ensemble de la population la
question de la solidification de la
solidarité intergénérationnelle et la
question de l'Un universalité du droit à
l'ensemble des travailleurs et des
citoyens de ce pays à partir ça ça
s'appelle le Plan Santé Travail et donc
on attend vous et ben que vous rouvriez
le débat et que vous fassiez en sorte
que le gouvernement respecte les
engagements qu'il avait pris ces
dernières semaines avant l'ouverture du
débat parlementaire voilà sur les
quelques points ah oui si quand même
trois points
sur parce que je suis en en l'occurrence
aussi responsable de la formation
professionnelle pour mon organisation
donc sur compte personnel d'Activ sur
compte personnel de formation et sur
apprentissage quelques points à vous
dire sur CPA moi ça me fait presque rire
ce que vous me dites sur le C3P il
existe pas encore et cetera oui pourquoi
il existe pas encore parce que les
patrons nen a pas voulu parce que ça a
été arraché par les organisations
syndicales dans la douleur et
qu'immédiatement après la création de ce
que c 3P on a cédé à une pression
patronale et on a complement
déréglementé l'été dernier la mise en
lumière de des des situations pénibles
de travail en décidant qu'on faisait des
référentiels de branche juste une petite
question alors aucune négociation
commence là au niveau des branche ça
affolle personne que les employeurs
veulent pas ouvrir des négociations sur
la question de la pénibilité là ça
affole beaucoup moins que de nous dire
que les les sal veulent pas négocier
dans
l'entreprise comment com on gère un
référentiel de branche avec des
situations pénibles différentes d'une
branche à l'autre dans un CPA qui a pour
objectif universalité portabilité et
reconnaissance de situation péniible
tout au long de la vie ça me paraît un
petit peu
incompatible et c'est complètement
contraire à la philosophie de sécurité
sociale professionnelle donc tout ça il
faut le il faut le retirer et
recommencer à travailler sérieusement
mais pour commencer à travailler
sérieusement là-dessus il faut dire et
vous êtes les représentants des citoyens
dans cet hémicycle il faut dire la
pénibilité doit être réparée même si ça
coûte aux employeurs et au bout du
compte la pénibilité elle doit
disparaître men mettons en place une
politique de santé publique et de santé
au travail de prévention sur la question
de la du compte personnel de formation
et cetera il y a plein de choses à
revoir j'en donne une on a fait des
propositions y compris dans le rapport
parlementaire d'évaluation le compte
personnel formation aujourd'hui
malheureusement parce que nous c'est un
dispositif qui va dans le bon sens de
portabilité que nous défendons
aujourd'hui c'est une usine à gaz
pourquoi c'est une usine à gaz parce
qu'on a créé des listes
professionnelles d'acè enfin de comment
dire de qui permettent d'accéder au CPF
qui sont incompréhensibles à la fois
pour les salariés et les privés d'emploi
simplement parce qu'on n' pas voulu dire
le CPF c'est un dispositif qui va vers
la qualification ça renvoie à ma
première intervention sur la remise en
cause des qualifications parce parce que
derrière qualification il y a
classification et salaire et parce qu'on
est dans une société qui ériig en Domme
la baisse du coût du travail voilà la
raison pour laquelle ce CPF doit être
repris et puis enfin apprentissage ben
nous on est favorable à ouvrir le débat
la CGT ça fait 2 ans et demi qu'on le
demande au gouvernement des assises de
l'alternance parce qu'on considère que
l'apprentissage c'est de la formation
initiale par alternance tout comme la
formation professionnelle en lycée
professionnel puisqu'il y a des périodes
de stage et qu' y a la question du
contrat de professionnalisation qui est
de la formation d'insertion qui ne peut
pas être confondu avec la formation
initiale par apprentissage qui a la
question de l' l'apprentissage
aujourd'hui dans l'enseignement
supérieur qui est le seul à se
développer et que tout ce sujet-l ça
mérite bien un débat citoyen public
national sur l'ensemble de ce qu'on veut
faire demain dans notre pays en matière
d'enseignement professionnel quelle que
soit la voie madame
descac merci d'abord un mot pour dire
que j'admire la dialectique consiste à
expliquer qu'il faut du débat et quand
le débat s'organise on nous on nous
explique que c'est la démonstration même
que le sujet dont on parle n'a pas
d'intérêt
euh sur la question de de de
l'articulation
entre les différents niveaux de
négociation la loi la
branche et
l'entreprise j'avoue que je je rejoins
assez la vision qui a a
été celle que vous avez exprimé monsieur
LEM moine sur le fait que on est dans un
mouvement ancien vous le faites remonter
une quinzaine d'années à 2001 à la CFDT
on le fait quasiment remonté à 1968 et
la question et la création de la section
syndicale c'estàdire que une des
revendications très fortes de la CFDT en
1968 se plaît à à à à nous redire a de
mon mare à chaque fois c'était vraiment
redonner la parole au terrain redonner
la parole au salariés et donner la
possibilité aux salariés de s'organiser
dans l'entreprise au sein des sections
syndicales d'entreprise donc c'était
vraiment déjà à cette époque-là le le le
le pressentiment que là devait se nouer
des choses dans l'intérêt bien compris à
la fois des entreprises et des salariés
sans remettre en cause les protections
du Code du travail le rôle de régulation
de la branche évidemment et et il nous
semble qu'on est effectivement là en
train de de d'aboutir ou en tout cas de
franchir une étape supplémentaire dans
dans ce chemin
euh pourquoi nous on considère que que
le le le projet à ce stade ne remet pas
en cause le rôle de la branche d'abord
il le réaffirme y compris dans les
dernières évolutions du texte ensuite
parce que le ce qui est réécrit dans le
texte aujourd'hui c'est pas l'ensemble
du code du travail c'est la partie sur
le temps de travail et que il nous
semble tout à fait légitime que sur des
sujets qui touchent le temps et
l'organisation du travail ce soit au
plus près du terrain que la négociation
se joue et et c'est pour ça qu'on a
peut-être l'impression qu' un espèce
d'effet d'optique que on a reporté en
zappant un peu la branche de de la loi
vers l'entreprise ceci étant depuis 2004
on peut déjà négocier beaucoup de choses
dans l'entreprise sauf que les branches
avaient mis justement ces fameux verrous
euh qui ne sont pas de notre point de
vue toujours pertinents bon mais quand
on sera quand la Commission et puis
ensuite le Parlement réécrira les autres
parties du Code du travail je je pense
par exemple à la question de l'emploi à
la question des parcours professionnels
et cetera à la question de la
représentation j'ai entendu dire tout à
l'heure que par accord on allait pouvoir
supprimer les IRP enfin c'est absolument
une c'est une vue de l'esprit c'est
c'est écrit ni euh ni ça nulle part bon
euh quand on en sera d'autres sujets on
verra bien que là du coup le rôle de
régulation de la branche sur les
qualifications par exemple sur les
parcours professionnels redeviendra
majeur c'est parce qu'on est en train
d'écrire la partie tant de travail
aujourd'hui qu'on a renvoyé beaucoup de
choses à la négociation d'entreprise
donc nous nous n'avons justement pas
d'inquiétude y compris parce que le
texte non seulement réaffirme le rôle de
régulation économique et sociale de la
branche mais parce qu'aussi il a créé
cette commission qui pourra faire un
bilan de la négociation collective de
branche qui est à la fois le garant pour
nous que cette négociation qu'on pourra
observer la la la la vitalité la
vitalité de la négociation dans les
entreprises mais sans remettre en cause
effectivement le rôle de régulation
économique et sociale alors vous dites
est-ce qu'on pourrait vous dites c'est
un mouvement l mais en même temps vous
proposez encore de le ralentir en disant
on pourrait aller à 50
% par étape alors nous on y est pas
favorable d'abord parce qu'on on estime
que les étapes elles sont déjà lentes
que la position commune que nous avons
signée avec la CGT en particulier sur
cette question en 2008 vous imaginez
2008 hein ça fait déjà un moment et que
l'idée c'était de changer
progressivement de culture à cette
époque- là on était déjà là-dedans on
fait une première étape à 30 et puis
ensuite on ira à 50 donc nous on estime
qu'il y a eu un gap culturel qui a déjà
été passé sur la culture de l'engagement
dans le syndicalisme c'est d'ailleurs
pas par hasard si on soulligne toujours
que toutes les organisations syndical
hein quel que soient les positions
qu'elles prennent d'ailleurs au niveau
national ell signent des accords dans
les entreprises quand elles sont
confrontées à la réalité des besoins à
la fois des entreprises et des salariés
et que donc il faut aller au au bout
maintenant de cette logique le temps est
venu d'aller au bout de cette logique de
la culture de l'engagement c'est vrai
que euh ce ce ce qui fait que euh à
l'inverse d'autres pays européens mais
aussi ailleurs dans le monde il y a une
crise passion forte qui qui se noue dans
le débat public en France autour de
cette question des accords d'entreprise
c'est que euh on on vit toujours dans
une espèce de culture selon laquelle il
faudrait se méfier de la négociation
qu'elle est peut-être pas toujours apte
à passer les bons compromis que la
culture du conflit est peut-être celle
qui permet de de de de de faire avancer
les les les les droits pour les salariés
alors même que ces 20 dernières années
ont montré absolument le contraire je je
je vous mets au défi de citer un droit
nouveau acquis
euh par la lutte euh ces dernières
années euh concrètement la négociation
d'entreprise de branch et la négociation
nationale interprofessionnelle a a
permis non seulement de de de créer
beaucoup de droits nouveaux pour les
salariés le droit rechargeable à
l'assurance chômage le compte personnel
de formation qui est quand même un
acquis issu de euh de de la de la
négociation le compte personnel
pénibilité j'en dis un mot même si c'est
pas complètement dans l'ordre des
questions compte personnel de pénibilité
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est l'idée
justement qu'on a réussi à obtenir par
la négociation et par la concertation
ensuite dans la loi que face au défi qui
était posé à nous sur l'équilibre des
régimes de retraite lié à des situations
conjoncturelles mais aussi une situation
structurelle d'allongement de la durée
de vie en bonne santé qui é quand même
plutôt une bonne nouvelle face à ce défi
qui nous est posé on pouvait
collectivement accepter de travailler
plus longtemps mais qu'en contrepartie
il fallait prendre en considération la
situation des gens qui eux n'étaient pas
en bonne santé et que le travail pouvait
rendre malade donc le compte personnel
euh de pénibilité donc j'entends avec
stupeur que la CGT voudrait arriver à le
supprimer c'est à la fois l' qui permet
et la prévention et la réparation
pourquoi la prévention parce que
justement il y a un volet formation dans
le compte personnel de prévention de
comme son nom l'indique de pénibilité
qui permet de faire de la formation pour
échapper aux situations de travail
pénible et qui a aussi un outil de
réparation pour permettre de partir de
façon anticipée en retraite bon
donc voilà les acquis de la négociation
sont nombreux et je crois qu'il n'y a
aucune raison de craindre que les acquis
de la négociation dans les entreprises
soi inférieur à ce que à ce que sont les
acquis de la négociation au niveau
national interprofessionnel ou au niveau
des branches mais c'est vrai que il y a
une culture à changer qui est celle de
la culture de l'engagement dans notre
pays c'est vrai du côté des
organisations patronnales j reviendrai
mais c'est vrai aussi du côté des
organisations syndicales et autant nous
on considère que cette articulation
nouvelle qui est proposée là et comme
d'ailleurs je j'aime j'aime aussi bien
le ce que vous avez dit je crois que
c'est Monsieur gabouti de dire mais
après tout on on essaye une formule et
puis rien ninterdit de la retoucher si à
l'issue de bilan d'ailleurs c'est prévu
dans la loi qu' y a un bilan
parlementaire avant 2019 il y aura donc
un bilan dans les branches réalisées par
les acteurs eux-mêmes donc rien
n'interdit qu'on retouche à la marge les
frontières dont vous avez parlé mais à
ce stade je pense qu'il faut qu'on y
aille il faut qu'on aille vers cette
nouvelle articulation il faut qu'on
aille vers l'accord majoritaire parce
que c'est lui qui garantit la qualité du
point de vue des accords et de même
l'articulation entre démocratie
représentative et démocratie directe
avec le référendum la façon dont c'est
formulé aujourd'hui dans le texte de loi
nous paraît aussi une initiative
peut-être audacieuse mais intéressante
il faut l'expérimenter il faut le faire
parce que pour moi il n'y a pas de
contradiction entre la capacité des
organisations syndicales à représenter
les salariés d'autant plus que depuis
2008 et grâce toujours à la position
commune la validité des accords se
mesure grâce au fait que les salariés
votent et font et et et donnent
confiance ou pas aux organisations
syndicales mais pour moi elle n'est pas
contat victoire avec le fait que et bien
de temps en temps et vous avez cité
l'accord sur la fonction publique un
accord qui est validé à 49 % par des
organisations syndicales euh qui qui
d'ailleurs on ne sait pas trop les 51 %
qui ne l'ont pas signé si ell s'y
opposent si elles juste ne l'ont pas
signé pour des raisons internes dont on
a du mal à mesurer parfois la réalité
des des fondements et cetera bon si on
avait pu plutôt que de s'en remettre à
une décision unilatérale de l'État un
autre employeur on aurait hurlé à la
mort hein n'importe quel autre employeur
on aurait dit c'est un scandale bon si
au lieu d'utiliser cette procédure on
avait pu simplement demander aux gens
mais mais mais qu'en pensez-vous mais
qu'en pensez-vous en quoi c'est- il
légitime quand justement on ne les
interroge pas sur une question aléatoire
pour reprendre l'expression de Franck
est-ce que vous pouvez est-ce que je
sais pas que pensez-vous de la pluie et
du B temp voilà si si si le le
référendum n'est pas manipulé si
justement parce que ce sont les
organisations syndicales qui en ont
l'initiative sur la B d'un accord qui a
été préalablement négocié donc qui a
fait l'objet de débat dans l'entreprise
si ces mêmes organisations syndicales
sont suffisamment à proximité avec les
salaries qu'ell représent pour prendre
ce risque à notre avis elles le
prendront rarement parce
qu'ell elles se sentiront légitimes par
le par le vote des salariés et par la
signature ou non de l'accord la la
représentativité sera mesurée la messe
sera dite mais dans un certain nombre de
cas il se peut qu'il y ait besoin
effectivement de débloquer les
situations et seules les organisations
syndicales qui ont suffisamment de
proximité avec les salariés prendront ce
risque du référendum donc nous on pense
on n sait rien si ça si ça aura toutes
les vertus qu'on qu' qu'on met dans ce
dispositif mais on pense qu'en tout cas
c'est une expérimentation à tenter et
qu'en 2009 en 2019 pardon au moment où
le bilan sera venu de cette de cette
expérimentation et bien il sera temps de
voir si elle a porté ses fruits et s'il
y a des ajustements possible à à mettre
en œuvre alors du coup ça répond un peu
à votre proposition de de commission
paritaire est-ce qu'il faut renforcer
euh par la loi le rôle de la commission
paritaire je je je je je dirais plutôt
que non d'abord si ces commissions
paritaires ne fonctionnent pas c'est la
démonstration peut-être à soit tout seul
que le dispositif n'est pas pertinent al
pour le coup ça reviendrait à inverser
d'une drôle de manière la la légitimité
de mesurer le principe de faveur on a
dit tout à l'heure que c'était au plus
près du terrain les salariés et leurs
représentants qui étaient capable de
dire si le principe de faveur était à
leur sens respecté parce que l'accord
leur apporter des avantages et là on
irait redire à la branche mais oui mais
vous avez un espèce de contrôle à
postériori euh une espèce de de de de
droit de censure si ça ne marche pas
aujourd'hui c'est parce que ce n'est pas
efficace et parce que ce n'est pas utile
donc moi je je je je serais plutôt pour
dire met-toi en œuvre le dispositif
faisons-en un bilan sérieux en 2019 et
voyons s'il y a des ajustements à
apporter euh sur la négociation dans les
TPE qui a été abordé alors aujourd'hui
euh euh le on soulligne à juste titre
qu'il y a une insuffisance de
représentation des salariés des TPE je
commence peut-être par la fin de votre
question monsieur GAB Bouri quand vous
dites euh finalement il y a des accords
de faête et c'est aussi bien on ne
formilise rien mais vous employez des
mots de bonne volonté de bonne entente
généralisé je je n'y crois pas bien
parce que justement à cause de ce qu'on
a dit tout à l'heure et que mes
collègues ont bien développé la question
du lien de subordination hein euh la la
bonne entente elle ne peut pas se
présumer quand il n'y a pas justement
d'intermédiation et quand on est dans un
lien par une organisation syndicale ou
ou un élu du personnel et quand on est
dans un lien de subordination avec son
employeur donc moi je pense qu'il y a un
certain nombre de dispositifs à mettre
en œuvre pour que le droit
constitutionnel des salariés des TPE à
être représentés soit réel ça ça existe
en partie dans le cadre de la loi
repsamè avec la création des commissions
paritaires régionales mais dont les
attributions sont limitées donc l'idée
de dire que dans les TPE il peut y avoir
des modalités aussi d'adaptation des
règles pour le bénéfice des entreprises
et des salariés me paraît une bonne idée
et que ce ce ces adaptations des règles
elles puissent être mise en œuvre
aujourd'hui par des dispositifs variés
hein vous avez cité la possibilité de
négocier pour les institutions
représentatives du personnel mais ça
existe et la loi ne le supprime pas au
contraire le mandatement c'est c'est
quelque chose qui arrive en plus donc et
et la loi rajoute de surcroix une
modalité supplément ire qui est celle de
la cortipe pour le coup négocier dans la
branche que demander de mieux puisqu'on
veut de la régulation de branche puisque
aussi il y a un sujet là de
simplification pour les TPE qui n'ont
pas forcément toujours les les les les
les compétences en interne pour négocier
des accords un peu complexes un chef
d'entreprise dans une PME ou une TPE
encore plus dans une TPE qui a le choix
aujourd'hui entre mettre en œuvre un
accord type négocier avec ses IRP
demander un mandatement il me semble que
là il y a un éventail de possibilités de
négociation et d'adaptation des règles
dans les pe qui me paraissent aussi
aller dans le bon sens et qui devront
comme le reste faire l'objet faire
l'objet d'un bilan mais là aussi je
pensCe que il y a j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure de changer de culture du côté
des des organisations syndicales de
salariés il y a évidemment un changement
de culture majeur à à attendre non
seulement des organisations syndicales
patronnales mais aussi peut-être d'une
certaine partie du patronat qui ne
connaissant pas
euh les organisations syndicales en en
ont une représentation largement erroné
et s'imagine que on l'entend parfois
dire comme ça hein dans dans la bouche
de certains représentants des
organisations patronnales un
représentant du personnel ou un ou un un
salarié syndiqué dans son entreprise
dans salarié syndiqué il y a bien
salarié on est salarié de l'entreprise
he avant d'être syndiqué et bien il y
aurait là une espèce de de la lutte des
classes entrerait dans les entreprises
et il n'urait qu'une seule visée les
détruire mais c'est le contraire qui se
passe c'est le contraire qui se passe
c'est la un salarié mandaté un salarié
adhérant à une organisation syndicale
c'est Laib possibilité pour lui d'être
formé de comprendre les enjeux
économiques sociaux les règles
techniques liées à la sécurité au
travail par exemple et cetera et pour
moi ça apporte une valeur ajoutée que
beaucoup de de chefs d'entreprise
sous-estim justement dans le dialogue un
véritable dialogue social et pas
seulement des relations sociales dans
l'entreprise donc moi je je je je pense
aussi que cette possibilité de
mandatement elle peut aussi amener
contribuer à ce changement de culture
des chefs d'entreprises qui
s'apercevront comme c'est déjà le cas
dans un certain nombre de de
d'entreprises grandes et surtout moyenne
dans beaucoup de PME où on peut déjà
constater que le dialogue social sauve
des entreprises sauve des entreprises en
anticipant et en discutant dans le cadre
des IRP par exemple des comités
d'entreprises sur la stratégie de
l'entreprise réorient cette stratégie
font des contrepropositions et cetera
mais aussi sauve des entreprises dans
des situations de difficultés économique
majeur vous en avez probablement dans
vos territoires des tas
d'exemples un mot enfin sur le compte
personnel sur le compte personnel
d'activité pour
dire pour ajouter à ce que j'ai déjà
assez largement développé tout à l'heure
d'abord vous
dites monsieur fuisser c'est c'est en
fait la compilation de trois comptes à
ce stade vous avez raison il y a un mot
qui n'est pas utilisé dans cette loi qui
n'a pas non plus été utilisé dans le
relevé de conclusions signé par les
partenaires sociaux parce que le
patronat s est opposé mais qui viendra
forcément et qui viendra forcément dès
après le vote de la loi c'est le mot
fongibilité fongibilité entre les
comptes bien sûr que ces comptes ils ont
vocation à fonctionner ensemble dans un
objectif commun qui est celui de la
sécurisation des parcours professionnels
et on voit bien d'ailleurs déjà qu'il y
a des des points de de de convergence
entre le compte personnel de formation
et le compte personnel de prévention de
la pébilité puisqu'il y a des
possibilités de financer de la formation
qui sont prévues dans les deux donc bien
sûr qu'il y aura la possibilité
d'organiser de la fongibilité entre ses
comptes pour que ce ne soi pas des
outils qui fonctionnent de façon
parallèle j'en profite pour dire que le
compte de prévention d'ppébilité il est
faux de dire qu'il n'est pas en
application il est en application on
peut déjà sur les 6 des 10 critères de
la loi mettre en œuvre enfin les
salariés peuvent déjà ont déjà des
droits inscrits à leur compte sur 6 des
10 critères du compte personnel de
prévention de la pénibilité il reste un
certain nombre de sujets à régler dans
la dans le cadre de la négociation de
branche et au niveau interprofessionnel
dans dans le cadre aussi de la médiation
parce qu'on qu' y a des critères qui
sont difficiles à mettre en œuvre donc
nous nous y allons pour ce qui concerne
la CFDT avec une volonté de
simplification pour que ces droits
soient effectifs donc c'est pas parce
que c'est difficile qu'on ne va pas y
aboutir mais encore une fois c'est un un
droit majeur pour les salariés en
particulier pour les salariés le plus
exposés à des risques professionnels
donc nous nous tenons à sa mise en œuvre
effective et complète
euh que vous dire d'autre alors oui vous
parler d'une formule intéressante du
statut des actifs plutôt que du statut
des travailleurs alors vous avez raison
en tout cas s'agissant du CPA euh moi je
pense que
euh limiter le compte personnel
d'activité à la au strict champ de
l'activité professionnelle est un peu
réducteur notamment à cause de cette ce
fameux allongement de la durée de vie en
bonne santé et de la complexification
des parcours je crois que de plus en
plus on va aller vers un un passage
entre l'activité et la retraite qui sera
à la fois plus progressif et à la fois
multiforme euh euh euh non seulement
parce qu'on réduira son activité
professionnelle peut-être plus
progressivement mais parce qu'il y aura
peut-être des allers-retours parce que
ça va plus se mélanger aussi avec une
activité militante ou associative et
donc du coup c'est la raison pour
laquelle je trouve que j'ai toujours
trouvé qu'arrêter le compte personnel
d'activité au moment où liquide ses
droits à retraite c'était
potentiellement réducteur un exemple on
peut très bien avoir besoin une fois
qu'on est en retraite pour son
investissement
militant ou associatif de de d'avoir
accès à une formation particulière et et
du coup je trouve que là le CPA pourrait
pourrait jouer toute sa
place enfin un petit mot sur sur la
question de l'apprentissage alors c'est
vrai que c'est une énigme française euh
il y a des réformes de l'apprentissage
peut-être pas tous les ans mais au moins
tous les 2 ans et on on a du mal à
comprendre pourquoi un dispositif qui
sur le papier paraît à ce point
pertinent utile aux jeunes à tous les
jeunes d'ailleurs quel que soit leur
niveau d'étude pour les amener à
l'emploi utile aux entreprises pour
avoir des jeunes formés à la fois en
théorie mais aussi en pratique à leur
culture professionnelle on a du mal à
comprendre pourquoi ça marche pas
euh il est probable que la gouvernance
de ces questions soit un petit peu
complexe et qu'il faille que tout le
monde s'y repenche l'État les régions et
les partenaires sociaux mais en tout cas
je tiens à vous redire ici la totale
implication des partenaires sociaux en
particulier de la CFDT sur cette
question de l'apprentissage et de
l'accès à l'emploi des jeunes Force
Ouvrière monsieur Lemine vous nous dites
que la nouvelle articulation est décrite
comme une véritable révolution euh pour
nous c'est une révolution hein dans le
sens où elle modifie complètement et
qu'elle apporte une véritable rupture
dans les modes de relations sociales
pour nous c'est une révolution alors
vous évoquez la négociation de 2001 et
je rappelle quand même que à cette
époque là
effectivement notre organisation
syndicale n'est pas contre les la
négociation d'entreprise hein c'est
c'est clair et qu'en
2001 la la branche gardait toutes les
prérogatives qu'elle a aujourd'hui de
négociation au
niveau national hein et tout à et on
était déjà encore en 2001 dans le
respect de la hiérarchie des normes donc
ça c'est c'est c'est important euh je
crois qu'on peut aussi évoqué 1982 avec
les lois au roues qui ont prévu
justement les premières dérogations au
code au code du travail mais là on n
plus dans les dérogations on est dans le
supplétif et en terme de droit collectif
ça peut-être encore plus dangereux euh
si rien n'est prévu si rien n'est cadré
au départ et et ça peut être encore plus
dangereux pour les salariés donc faut
faut je pense que ça c'est quelque chose
d'important qu'on qu'on qu'on doit avoir
en tête de faire en sorte que la loi
cadre bien le 3ème niveau du supplétif
de façon à ce qu'on aille pas au-delà du
système dérogatoire qui existe
actuellement ça ça me paraît quand même
assez fondamental ensuite moi je suis
pas de ceux qui
veulent faire un lien ou comparer la
démocratie politique avec la démocratie
sociale c'est deux choses complètement
différentes la démocratie sociale on est
dans le cadre de de l'entreprise avec le
lien de subordination qui qui qui joue
comm même fortement sur ces questions de
de démocratie il y a aussi cet aspect de
l'intérêt général que vous vous portez
en en tant qu'élu de de la nation et
nous en tant que républicain on y est
fortement attaché et cet intérêt
particulier que nous nous représentons
et nous faisons bien le distingo nous ào
de l'intérêt entre l'intérêt particulier
des salariés que nous représentons et
l'intérêt général que vous portez donc
ça ça c'est c'est c'est c'est important
de de de le redire quand à la branche je
crois que elle peut renvoyer ce qu'elle
veut à l'entreprise tout et d'ailleurs
elle peut aujourd'hui déjà renvoyer un
un un maximum de choses à partir du
moment où on va améliorer les droits à
partir du moment où on respecte le
principe de faveur pour nous ça nous
porte aucun euh ça ça ça ça il y a aucun
problème euh euh à ça après sur
l'évolution de de 30 à à 50
effectivement vous l' vous l'avez
souligné c'est plus compliqué euh ce
sera plus compliqué effectivement de
signer un accord à 50 % et qu'à 30 euh
plutôt qu'à 30 % je crois que pour
laisser vivre la négociation et bien euh
euh aujourd'hui un accord à 30 % euh est
largement satisfaisant à partir du
moment où il y a un droit d'opposition
et je pense que on peut regarder toutes
les organisations syndicales qui peuvent
bénéficier du droit d'opposition ne vont
pas le faire jouer systématiquement pour
laisser vivre la négociation collective
voilà c'est ça ça me paraît quand même
fondamental de laisser vivre ce droit
d'opposition à la main des organisations
syndicales qui sont euh qui sont
majoritaires ensuite est évoqué la
question euh de la démocratie directe et
de la possibilité donc pour les IRP euh
euh de signer euh des accords alors je
ne sais pas si les salariés qui sont non
syndiqués sont aussi légitimes que ceux
qui ne le sont pas ça on pourrait aussi
engager euh une discussion assez large
là-dessus mais il est clair que pour
nous euh c'est une c'est encore une fois
de plus un contournement des
organisations syndicales c'est c'est ça
ça ça ça n'est rien d'autre alors en
entre le référendum le mandatement ça
fait beaucoup de choses parce
qu'effectivement nous on considère que
le mandatement c'est encore un
dispositif qui vise à contourner les
organisations syndicales parce qu'on
sait très bien comment ça s'est passé l
lors des de la loi au BRI on a vu des
salariés arrivés à le monde de leur
employeur dans une organisation
syndicale pour signer des accords voilà
hein voilà donc ça ce sont des des des
salariés mandatés par l'employeur c'est
clair donc nous on est beaucoup on est
on on est plus en phase avec la
possibilité de désigner un représentant
syndical dans l'entreprise sans même
d'heur
d'heur syndical et cetera mais qui
puisse être désigné à la main des
organisations syndicales ça ça nous
paraît beaucoup plus légitime que le le
mandatement tel qu'il est prévu
aujourd'hui la question ce serait de de
savoir pourquoi justement on on a des
des salariés qui sont élus et qui ne
sont pas syndiqués ça ça ça c'est une
vraie question et on connaît hein les
questions de discrimination euh dont
sont victimes les les euh les salariés
syndiqués parce que lorsqu'on n pas
salariés protégés on a tout intérêt à à
à dire au salariés qu' qu'il n'annonce
pas son employeur qu'il est qu'il est
syndiqué parce que la plupart du temps
la première chose que va faire un
employeur je dis pas tous tous les
employeurs mais c'est c'est d'essayer de
s'en séparer de ce de de de de ce
salarié on on a on a les chiffres
justement des des des des salariés
mandat syndiqués et mandatés euh victime
donc de de discrimination syndicale et
ça reste quand même important pourtant
les les les les les employeurs devraient
quand même avoir une réflexion on sait
par exemple que 80 % des dossiers prudom
sont issus d'entreprises où il y a pas
de présence syndicale on sait que les
organisations syndicales dans les
entreprises et bien favorisent justement
la discussion et font en sorte que et
bien on aille pas jusqu'au prudom pour
défendre défendre les salariés donc
l'organisation syndicale dans
l'entreprise n'est pas un frein au
dialogue social à la compétitivité et
cetera et cetera donc je crois là aussi
que à ce niveau-là s'il y a un
changement de culture à avoir je pense
aussi qu'il est de et surtout de de de
ce de ce
côté-là sur la question de la médecine
du du travail
euh moi je crois que ce soit la question
du du certificat d' attitude ou ou tous
les dispositifs qui sont contenus dans
dans dans dans dans le chapitre de la
médecine du travail visent à contourner
le déficit et le manque de d'effectif
des médecins du travail ça c'est c'est
clairement on espace les visites c'est
plus des visites c'est des entretien il
y a il y a un glissement de tâche des
des des médecins du travail vers vers
d'autres personnels je crois qu'il faut
absolument aujourd'hui qu' rendre
beaucoup plus attractif cette cette
spécialité de la médecine du travail qui
ne doit pas rester l'enfant pauvre de de
de la médecine et faire en sorte que et
bien il puisse y avoir un vrai
recrutement de de de médecins euh du
travail parce que aujourd'hui euh dans
euh le regroupement des instances
représentatives hein dans dans les
délégation unique du personnel on voit
que les missions du CHSCT vont être
complètement diluées et que la question
justement de la santé euh de la sécurité
au travail vont être
euh ne vont ne vont plus être aussi
importante que elle ne l'était
auparavant et je crois que que c'est
question de la médecine du travail parce
que c'est une médecine préventive il y a
des travailleurs pauvres qui rencontrent
une fois ou deux fois par an ou de une
fois tous les 2 ans le médecin c'est
dans le cadre du du du travail et ça
c'est important de de le préserver parce
qu'il y a un certain nombre de
pathologies qui sont directement liées
au au au travail et qui vont qui vont
passer
malheureusement à côté euh je vais très
vite pour laisser la parole à à ma
collègue donc sur la question du CPA je
veux pas revenir sur ce que ce qu'on a
dit mais c'est vrai que le C3P c'est
quand même quel un dispositif qui a
justifié la retraite à 62 ans ça nous
coûte cher quand même he et aujourd'hui
on voit un petit peu certains freiner
des cas de faire pour le pour le mettre
en place et et je dois dire que là c'est
c'est quand même assez regrettable mais
ne chargeons pas la barque faisons déjà
avec ce qui existe dedans pas sûr que ça
fonctionne et on on on on verra au fur
et à mesure du temps lorsque ces
dispositifs c'est vrai que l'engagement
citoyen il a c'est c'est quelque chose
de de de flou et en tout cas pour ce qui
nous concerne nous le le passage à la
retraite et bien c'est c'est c'est c'est
le passage qui nous permet donc de
liquider ces droits si les salariés à la
retraite sont obligés de travailler on
connaît on on connaît les raisons pour
lesquelles ils sont obligés de le faire
c'est le niveau des retraites qui ne
cesse de baisser et on est obligé de
voir aujourd'hui des papis au boulot
jusqu'à 70 ans pour pouvoir encore vivre
dignement et ça justement qu'on fasse un
mélange entre le travail et la retraite
c'est quelque chose que nous ne
supportons pas à la retraite on a bossé
40 ou 42 ou 45 ans et bien on a le droit
à une retraite pour se reposer et non
pas pour
travailler merci alors moi sur la la
branche le rôle de la branche je
souhaitis insister sur la vitalité de
négociation qui existe dans les branches
le bilan de la
négociation bilan de la nég néociation
collective faite par le ministère du
Travail chaque année démontre la
vitalité de négociation qui existe au
niveau des branches et donc qui est donc
le niveau qui protège l'ensemble des
salariés je dirais c'est donc la
hiérarchie des garanties sociales donc
des salariés mais aussi donc des
entreprises c'est ce niveau qui évite
justement qu'il y ait une concurrence
entre les entreprises de même secteur
d'activité soit parce que les grandes
ont les moyens de payer donc des heures
supplémentaires euh allant jusqu'à 25
même 50 % et que les autres de du même
secteur d'activité n'ont pas les mêmes
possibilités soit parce que aussi donc
tous les salariés de même secteur
d'activité bénéficient des mêmes
garanties des mêmes droits C dem main
justement de une négociation euh dans le
cas de la primuté donnée à à à l'accord
d'entreprise vous aurez donc à la fois
un dumping entre donc les entreprises de
même secteur d'activité mais aussi des
salariés de même secteur d'activité et
donc une concurrence et et alors je sais
que beaucoup de d'entreprises en tous
les cas notamment euh les TP PME ne sont
pas forcément favorables à ce genre de
de euh d'accord dans la mesure où c'est
la branche qui protège aussi ses
entreprises et beaucoup de fédérations
patronales sont très attachées justement
au niveau de la branche parce qu' un
enjeu considérable pour les petites et
les moyennes entreprises et pour
certaines entreprises aussi et puis il y
a une autre difficulté qui donc des sal
qu donc des salariés et donc des
entreprises de ces salariés qui sont
dépouvus de fait et de droit d'irp et de
représentants donc de syndicaux
simplement parce que les entreprises qui
sont normalement assujetties aux organ
aux élections professionnelles pour
permettre aux organisations syndicales
de s'implanter et ben n'organise pas
d'élection je vous invite à regarder le
bilan qui fait par le Haut Conseil du
dialogue social sur la mesure de
l'audience de 2012 et et aussi donc les
rapports qui ont été faits et qui
démontrent bien qu'il y a très peu il y
a énormément d'entreprises qui
ne ne concourt pas donc aux élections
professionnelles et donc on parle aussi
de du taux de syndicalisation qui est
faible en France mais tout est fait pour
éviter que les organisations syndicales
ne s'implantent pas dans dans
l'entreprise et avec le mandatement ça
va être exactement la même chose donc
c'est pour cette raison que il est
important de de recourir à une
possibilité de désigner en représentant
syndical dans l'entreprise concernant
donc la négociation euh au niveau de
l'entreprise je rappelle pour pour
autant que déjà la négociation annuelle
obligatoire au regard donc des remontées
que nous avons c'est souvent un problème
parce que les entrepris ont une
obligation d'ouvrir les négociations
mais nonont pas d'obligation de
conclure alors que au niveau de la
branche on négocie on conclu un accord
et ça couvre l'ensemble des salariés de
même secteur d'activité je veux bien
qu'on dise que bon euh ça crée une
vitalité ça permet donc au au au au au
salariés d'être acteur sauf qu'on n'est
pas dans dans la vraie vie ça ne se
passe pas ainsi parce que quand vous
êtes face un employeur qui vous dit vous
allez remettre en cause vos droits sinon
je licencie mais sans vous donner les
éléments sans vous prouver qu'il y a un
risque pour l'entreprise et après vous
apprenez que l'entreprise va se
délocaliser ù l'entreprise donc
bénéficie d'un certain nombre d'aide et
finalement ne n'investit pas dans
l'entreprise donc on est on a à la foid
donc il y a un problème
non seulement de loyauté de la
négociation que nous avons posé dans le
cadre de ce projet de texte mais un
problème d'accessibilité aussi au au aux
informations qui concernent la marge
générale de l'entreprise contrairement
donc à cette base de données unique qui
est prévu dans dans la
loi dans la loi resamen et qui ne permet
pas justement de négocier les conditions
justement de d'accessibilité à
l'information utile pour une négociation
euh je dirais circonstancié alors nous
sommes donc à la fois dans dans dans
dans face à une situation qui est quand
même assez complexe et compliquée où
donc on nous fait miroiter que au niveau
d'entreprise et bien on va renforcer le
dialogue social et bien si c'était le
cas je vous assure qu'il y aura eu
beaucoup plus d'accord au niveau
d'entreprise voilà et c'est parce qu'il
y a donc des accords de branche parce
qu'il y a ce niveau de branche que ça
crée une dynamique de négociation tion
au niveau de l'entreprise parce que ça
impose donc oblige les entreprises à
négocier sous les sujets qui sont donc
négociés au niveau au niveau de la
branche et et je ne je je n'en parle
même pas sur les conséquences en matière
à la fois de euh euh de de salaire de
classification et cetera donc nous
sommes face à une situation importante
et puis l'autre l'autre euh difficulté
je tiens à insister sur la question donc
de de l'accord majoritaire et et
notamment euh sur euh la la la
difficulté en terme d'absence donc
d'opposition pour euh pour donc les
organisations syndicales mais notamment
aussi la fragilisation de du syndicat et
le rôle que l'on veut faire jouer au
syndicats dans ce dans ce pays la
question elle est vraiment posée et si
on regarde ce bilan je j'insiste sur le
bilan de de du rapport du Haut Conseil
du dialogue social c'est très édifiant
et vous verrez que nous ne parlons pas
de la même chose ça a été fait par des
par à la fois la Darest mais par aussi
des chercheurs et c'est très
significatif sur justement la façon dont
on parle et en consçu le dialogue social
et terminer pour terminer sur les
commissions permanentes alors euh de la
branche alors je dirais que je dis les
commissions paritaires pourquoi les
commissions paritaires ne fonctionn ont
des difficultés c'est parce que
l'administration du travail n'a pas de
moyen n'a pas de moyens pour voir
désigner un président de commission
paritaire mixte et donc avec la
commission permanente ça va être la même
chose alors alors je veux bien qu'on
prévoir des tas de choses mais aussi il
faudrait qu'on prévoir les moyens pour
l'administration du travail pouvoir
permettre ces commissions à ces
commission permanente de de de de de
fonctionner or une commission permanente
c'est pour le bilan il a un bilan sur la
négociation deux branches qui est faite
chaque année par l'administration du
travail au regard à la fois des éléments
que l'administration du travail possède
mais que les organisations syndicales
envoi et que les organisations
patronales donc envoi également donc je
ne suis
pas certaine que cette commission
permanente soit d'une sérieuse utilité
pour faciliter justement une une
dynamique de négociation et un contrôle
sur les négociations au niveau donc des
entreprises merci Monsieur
micula un peu dans la même veine pour
prendre un peu la suite sur cette
question de de parèle
entre le le syndicat les politiques donc
bon on a déjà eu l'occasion de parler de
ça mais avec tout le respect que je vous
dois je vais continuer de de vous agacer
avec mes
raisonnements parce que je pense que
effectivement ces parallèles ont du
sens je dis pas qu'on fait le même
métier mon collègue parlait d'intérêt
général je partage tout à fait ce point
de vue je parle plutôt moi d'intérêt
commun dans le champ de entreprise mais
c'est vrai que l'intérêt général c'est
vous mais il y a quelque
chose que vous savez mais comme je
l'entends mais tous les jours soit à la
radio soit la télé soit dans le journal
les syndicats ne représentent personne
c'est génial
ça je sais pas alors on cite des fois 3
4 5 % c'est ridicule
euh je pense que c'est grave c'est grave
il y a deux choses qui sont
graves le fait qu'on ne parvienne pas
pas euh à avoir plus
d'adhérents le fait que les partis
politiques ne parviennent pas à avoir
plus d'adhérents de la même façon pour
ça je fais ce parallèle c'est le même
problème et je pense que ce problème là
il est
grave mais ça ne veut pas dire que vous
n'êtes pas légitime et ça ne veut pas
dire que nous ne sommes pas légitimes
parce que nous notre légitimité c'est
vous qui l'avez décidé elle repose sur
l'élection on doit être élu et
effectivement ben on est élu he on est
élu dans les entreprises on est élu dans
les entreprises avec un taux de
participation qui est et ben je le
crains supérieur au taux de
participation des élections politiques
sauf peut-être l'élection du Président
de la
République mais c'est pas mais c'est un
cheveux donc on a vraiment ce
problème qui me tient à cœur c'est celui
de la démocratie représentative je pense
que notre société est fondé là-dessus
c'est vital le jour où on oubliera ce
mode de représentation des salariés on
s'expose à un grand péril on le voit la
marge de temps à autre survenir et ça
nous inquiète tous parce qu'on sait pas
où ça nous amène on a donc besoin tous
de renforcer cette
représentation en représentant les
citoyens pour vous les salariés pour
nous et aboutir à des nouveaux compromis
on est tous attachés à la recherche du
renforcement de ce dialogue social qui
permet d'aboutir à des
compromis 2001 vous nous dis vous nous
dites là déjà on avait prévu de renvoyer
à
l'entreprise ça m'amène à un autre une
autre évidence que je souhaite rappeler
ici la loi travail la loi comery n'a pas
inventé les accords
d'entreprise en disant il faut vite
faire des accords d'entreprise grâce à
ma loi on va faire des accords
d'entreprise mais de qui se moque-t-on
il y en a des milliers des accords
d'entreprises00 40000
ça existe et
heureusement ce qui est nouveau c'est
qu'on veut faire des accords
d'entreprise dérogatoire ah ah on oublie
de préciser c'est pour déroger déroger à
la norme à la norme conventionnelle
c'est la question que vous posiez depuis
2001 et donc celle de d'une de la
prolongation d'une inversion de la
hiérarchie des normes parce que en fait
il faut être précis ça existe depuis
longtemps C inversant de la hiérarchie
des normes et progressivement on le
législateur l'amplifie vous
l'amplifiez le dernier la grand dernière
grande étape c'était 2008 le temps de
travail négocié dans l'entreprise
maintenant allez on y va encore plus
fort en changeant la structure du Code
du travail alors on pourrait dire c'est
passer à trois ét trois étages ordre
publ ordre conventionnel et supplétif
c'est pas très grave effectivement on ça
pourrait être considéré comme plus
lisible euh c'est pas ça que je trouve
le plus plus choquant ce que je trouve
le plus choquant c'est quand dans la
même opération on renvoie la négociation
et on vide l'ordre public de sa
substance pour le renvoyer pardon à à la
suletivité S que ça a été pour bien
illustrer cette question celle des
congés d'un certain type de congés
familiaux bon ça a été corrigé mais
c'est juste pour illustrer et on dit
dans l'entreprise on pourra négocier tel
et tel type de congé
et à défaut on pourra le faire dans la
branche c'était donc priorité donnée à
l'entreprise et l'ordre supplétif disait
bah à défaut d'accord ça sera de jours
je pense qu'il s'agissait des congés
pour le décès d'un proche je crois j'ai
oublié un
peu ça voulait donc dire que par accord
on pouvait faire moins ah non non non
non tout le monde a dit c'est pas
possible et le législateur donc je fais
très vite dit ah bah non non non ok vous
avez raison on pourra pas faire moins
donc on le maintient dans la parti
supplétive en disant ah mais ça pourra
pas être moins que de c'està-dire la loi
donc on voit bien qu'on était on essaie
de
retricoter le principe de faveur c'est
ce qui existe aujourd'hui donc on
l'habille autrement et on dit bah au
lieu de dire la loi dit c'est 2 jours
mais pas d'accord vous pouvez faire
mieux non non non on vous fait un ordre
public social avec un ordre avec la
renvoie à la négociation bon à la fin
vous aurez pas le droit de faire moins
que ce que je prévoyais avant avec la
loi qu'est-ce qu'on s'embête pourquoi on
construit tout ça quoi et il reste
encore des endroits où il y a deux ou
trois un recul de l'ordre public un
renvoie la négociation où là on peut
déroger à toute la norme supérieure ils
sont de moins en moins nombreux mais ils
existent encore cejet de lo c'est ce qui
nous permet de dire qu'il y a bien
encore une inversion de la hiérarchie
desmes donc la question comme dit les
accords
d'entreprise doivent être
favorisé je disais c'est celui c'est la
question la dérogation mais il reste il
n reste pas moins qu'une question
important continue d'être posée c'est
comment mieux faire fonctionner la
négociation de branche
pas disparu comment
l'enrichir comment la rendre plus
riche et mieux la faire fonctionner
c'était l'objet notamment partiellement
du du
rapportel il fais de proposition
comment mieux former les acteurs
comment donner plus de moyens avec les
les de plus de moyens d'abord on a
besoin de plus de moyens pour faire
cette négociation dans la branche je
rappelle qu'il y en a pas aujourd'hui
quand je dis plus c'est qu'il en
faudrait tout simplement il y en a pas
je sais pas ce qui c'est je sais pas
quel est le numéro de téléphone de la
branche tiens c'est c'était l'un d'entre
vous qui me faisait cette réflexion mais
je le connais pas non plus le numéro de
téléphone de la branche j'aimerais bien
donc ça veut dire qu'on a vraiment un
travail à faire sur c'est quoi le numéro
de téléphone si on veut lui donner une
mission et je nous dans mon organisation
propose de lui confier des missions
quasiment des missions de service public
tellement on considère que c'est
important pour les PME TME PM TPE PME 1
il faut qu'il a un numéro de téléphone
mais il faut leur donner des missions
précises et savoir quel est l'acteur qui
va rendre ce service aux entreprises
alors je vous ferai pas la frond de vous
rappeler tout ça vous connaissez
parfaitement dans les grandes
entreprises il y a des DRH ptin coufin
et dans les PME et a le chef
d'entreprise qui doit savoir tout faire
son métier DRH expert comptable enfin il
doivent savoir Tout Faire donc
évidemment là il a besoin d'une
assistance il a besoin d'aide quelle est
la norme applicable dans mon champ dans
mon entreprise c'est pas simple des fois
donc c'est là il doit y avoir un numéro
de téléphone le mission de service
public qu'on confirit à la branche ce
serait trouver les acteurs qui
permettront de renseigner toutes les TPE
PME pour leur donner la norme applicable
sans aucune
ambiguïé autre effort qu'on qu'on doit
faire alors il y a les prémises ici dans
dans la loi c'est comment construire ces
fameux accord-types pour les TPE PME là
aussi c'est quels acteurs quels moyens
et il faut être très ambitieux là-dedans
je pense que c'est fondamental ce
problème de dialogue social qu'on a dans
les petites entreprises je ne crois pas
VO mon organisation ne croit pas au
mandatement on ne croit pas à la
négociation avec les élus syndiqué ou
non syndiqué c'est encore pire avec les
non syndiqué avec les élus tout ça on y
croit pas ça ne marche pas ça existe
déjà et on fait le constat que ça ne
fonctionne pas donc c'est pas la peine
d'aller en rajouter il faut trouver
autre chose et ce autre chose je pense
qu'on pour on devrait travailler sur les
moyens donnés à la branche pour fournir
un véritable service il il ne demande
pas tant de déroger à la norme que tout
simplement la connaître avoir de la
sécurité c'est ça qui qu' réclame de la
sécurité je veux être tranquille je veux
pas m'embêter avec ça je veux faire mon
métier et mon métier c'estingur
fabriquer tuyau je sais pas quoi c'est
ça mon métier et il faut les il leur
simplifier le travail et je pense
que on a
des réflexions à avoir là-dessus des
moyens d'amélioration encore du
dispositif qui existe
aujourd'hui
CPA question de est-ce qu'il faut
l'arrêter à la retraite par la retraite
je vous dis on on a eu ces on a étudié
enfin on a réfléchi à ces questions là
pendant la négociation qui a tourné
court euh la fin de l'année dernière et
euh pour me débarrasser de cette
question je disais ben le CPA c'est du
berceau au cercueil voilà parce qu'en
fait ça m'intéresse pas je pense qu' y
Atel c'est une manière de pas parler du
vrai
sujet on s'en fiche c'est à 2 ans 10 ans
12 ans 18 ans 80 ans je sais pas je sais
pas à quel âge on est vieux plus le
temps passe et plus moins je sais à quel
âge on est vieux euh je suis
pas donc c'est pas ça je crois le sujet
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on met dedans et
comment je le mobilise c'est la
fangibilité
euh on en parlait tout à l'heure c'est
ces questionslà qui sont fondamentales
qu'est-ce que j'ai dedans du temps
qu'est-ce que j'en fais de la formation
pro il y a un volet indubitablement sur
la sécurisation des parcours mon
organisation pense qu'on ne doit pas se
limiter à cet aspect sécurisation des
parcours professionnels ça doit être
dedans mais le CPA c'est mieux que ça
c'est plus grand que ça c'est répondre à
des aspirations des salariés pour une
plus grande autonomie dans la gestion de
son parcours professionnel tout au long
de la vie comment je j'arrête mon
travail pour faire autre chose élever
mes enfants faire de l'associatif euh
rien faire faire de la formation pro ça
les regardent ils ont envie de pouvoir
choisir ce qu'ils veulent quand ils
veulent un des moyens qu'on peut leur
fournir c'est leur permettre d'épargner
du
temps après le législateur peut très
bien trouver utile de dire mais si vous
avez tel type d'activité associative si
vous faites pompier volontaire dans ma
commune et ben moi je vous abonde votre
CPA je vais dégager un un budget dans ma
commune et on va vous donner des heures
ou des jours ou je sais pas quoi je vais
vous je veux vous inciter à avoir cette
activité socialement utile et ben
pourquoi pas youpi c'est une des
possibilités d'utiliser le CP je dis pas
que c'est ça qu'on doit faire c'est une
des possibilités à partir du moment où
on aura vous aurez créé cette brique
fondamentale que j'appelle le compte
temps on mettra du temps on mettra 10
ans 15 ans peut-être mais par le
dialogue social entre part sociaux on
trouvera le moyen de construire des
dispositifs après très compliqués qu'on
appellera usine à gaz mais je
rappellerai au passage quand même que
les usines à gaz ça marche bien dans
notre
pays et je répondrai parce que déjà je
suis peut-être un peu trop long
répondrai en pied à votre question sur
la médecine du travail euh en BIA parce
que je dirais pour pas répondre je
dirais que dans nos propositions il
figure le fait que nous demandons à ce
que les salariés en forfait jour soi
considérés comme des salariés soumis à
une comment on appelle ça observation
particulière un suivi particulier parce
que il y a un vrai sujet il y a un vrai
enjeu pour les salari forfait jour c'est
la souffrance au travail le
burnout difficile de traiter le
burnout ça fait longtemps que vous
essayez que nous essayons de trouver par
le mode curatif il faut le faire de
façon préventive en renforçant la
médecine du travail préventive sur ces
questionsl exactement
et alléger le dispositif mécine au
prétexte qu'il y a de moins en moins de
médecins du travail ça n'est pas
satisfaisant quand on en aura plus que
10 médecins du travail on fera quoi ça
montre bien qu'il faut se poser la
question bien en amont pourquoi j'en ai
pas comment je fais pour en avoir plus
c'est quoi les études c'est quoi la paye
c'est quoi cette filière pourquoi j'en
ai pas aujourd'hui il en reste je sais
pas alors on va dire quelques centaines
quelques quelques milliers peut-être je
connais pas bien mais pas suffisamment
il y en a de moins en moins ok bah
plutôt que d'adapter le niveau de
garantie qu'on donne au salariés
posons-nous la question de comment
renforcer les études et la création de
postes de médecin du
travail et donc c'était ma façon de
répondre en BIA à votre question et et
évidemment monsieurier foruissier le la
question de l'apprentissage est très
importante pour chacun d'entre nous ici
et effectivement je confirme on se
coltine ce sujet tous les ans ou tous
les 2 ans alors tantôt c'est les assises
de l'apprentissage tantôt c'est en il y
a toujours un grand nom une grande
annonce politique quel que soit le bord
politique on nous annonce toujours
500000 apprentis
quelques tous les ban de les chiqu là
tous les an nous dit ouais avec moi
500000 alors comme je dis à Cha fois je
me F du chiffre ça m'intéresse pas tout
simplement il faut que ça marche je ne
comprends pas plus que vous monsieur
fuier pourquoi il y a des pays où ça
marche bien et pourquoi chez nous ça
marche pas je suis allé voir les patrons
là-bas m'ont expliqué nous on prend des
apprentis pour les transformer comme
salarier et en France on m'explique ben
non moi je prends des apprentis pour
toucher des subventions voilà différ qui
m'a sauté à la figure c'est ça donc j'ai
intérêt à le virer même en cours de en
cours de de formation parce que j'en
prends un autre et puis hop je retouche
non c'est pas effectivement je fais bien
sûr madame vous avez raison je réponds
un peu en de façon caricaturale à cette
question mais néantmins je crois que
derrière tout ça il y a un peu de vrai
pourquoi nos entreprises n' embauchent
pas et je ne crois pas que ce soit
simplement une question de subvention
une question de grandes assises de
d'objectif politique certes il faut le
donner on est d'accord ça ne peut pas
être que ça et dans notre pays ça n'est
principalement que ça de la compole et
j'en rêai là merci compole communication
politique pardon oui monsieur
Jardon merci je vais essayer d'être très
synthétique concernant votre question
sur est-ce qu'on aurait pas 15 ans de
retard concernant la négociation
d'entreprise j'ai envie de dire
regardons pas le passé regardons
l'avenir
euh mais en effet je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure nous nous
croyons à la subsidiarité et à la
négociation au plus proche des réalités
du terrain concernant les les les
nouvelles règles des des 50 % qui se
substituent au droit d'opposition qui
existait
hier le faire parpalier pourquoi pas
là-dessus pas forcément d'a priori sur
cette question mais en tout état de
cause le pendant final
du droit d'opposition qui existait hier
ça doit être la possibilité pour les
pour les organisation syndicales
minoritaire de pouvoir continuer à jouer
leur rôle et donc en ça le le référendum
qui est déclenché uniquement à
l'initiative des organisations
syndicales minoritaires à un moment il
était question que le référendum soit
déclenché par le chef d'entreprise là
pour le coup ça posait vraiment une
grosse question de fond mais là c'est on
a des organis syndicales minoritaires
qui sont dans leur rôle de partenaire de
construction dans
l'entreprise il y a ils ont plus
possibilité de signer des accords du
fait de la nouvelle règle des 50
% hier ceux qui signaient pas avaient le
droit d'opposition aujourd'hui c'est
tout à fait légitime que les organis
syndicales minoritaires aient cette
possibilité de déclencher un référendum
des exemples je peux vous en donner des
catalogues moi je suis
du du monde agricole et et forestier
j'ai négocié dans dans mon entreprise
que je citerai pas un accord qui
prévoyait que que que que l'employeur
prenne à sa charge 90 % du coût de la
mutuelle frais de santé quandme très bel
accord CGT majoritaire enfin pardon une
organisation syndicale majoritaire non
sign n'a pas voulu signer l'accord et a
fait valoir son droit d'opposition sous
prétexte que c'est la CFTC qui qu' a
négocié ce cette C chosl au bout d'un
moment faut sortir de ces choses-là il
faut faire avancer le débat dans la dans
l'entreprise et si on voit
que on peut renclencher un dialogue ou
faire avancer les dispositifs en levant
des freins de type politique et pas du
tout pragmatique par rapport à l' rité
d'entreprise laissons-nous des outils
des vrais outils de négociation dans
l'entreprise et les organisations cas
minoritaires ont un rôle à jouer ou
sinon on a qu'à dire elles ont ont pu
non pu être autour de la table tout
simplement je pense pas que ce soit la
volonté des uns et des autres chacun un
rôle les organ majoritaires on un rôle
les organisations minoritaires ont un
rôle leur laisser la possibilité de
déclencher un référendum avec cette
nouvelle règle des 50% et donc tout à
fait légitime et
souhaitable
concernant si je reste dans l'entreprise
les accords conclus par des élus en cas
d'absence par des
syndicale là on peut être réservé sur ce
principe que je que je citais tout à
l'heure dans dans mes propos du fait
qu'il est indispensable dans
l'entreprise d'avoir des interlocuteurs
dans la négociation qui soi accompagné
et
formé le mandatement pour nous est une
réponse c'est la responsabilité de
chacun ici de mandater des personnes de
les suivre de les accompagner et ainsi
de
suite mais appartement où l'organisation
syndicale qui mandate joue pleinement
son rôle le mandatement a un sens dans
dans dans le cas présent bien bien voilà
il faut bien différencier
l'élu l'élu du du mandaté qui va aller
dans la négociation c'est bien une pour
nous c'est il faut favoriser que la
négociation soit menée par quelqu'un qui
soit mandaté qui soit accompagné la
négociation ça s'invente pas tous les
jours on rencontre nous des élus qui ne
sont pas syndiqués qui sont pas
étiquetés et on voit très très vite la
carence qu'ils peuvent avoir ils sont de
bonne foi de bonne volonté de faire
avancer les choses dans l'entreprise
mais ils sont limités par le fait que
ils ont pas tout le soutien juridique
l'accompagnement technique que
l'organisation syndicale peut offrir
assez euh assez assez mandatés donc
c'est important c'est important si on
veut une vraie qualité dans la
négociation dans l'entreprise
indépendamment des questions de bonne
volonté je
je je connais très bien la
TPE je connais très bien les TPE et je
vois tous les jours ce que vous citiez
tout à
l'heure l'employeur et le salarié qui
savent s'entendre entre eux qui de bonne
fois vont avoir des
pratiques et ça marche ils s'entendent
et le jour où il y a un souci quelconque
ça termine au prudom et on voit qu'on
est complètement en dehors des clous
c'est ça n'offre pas de sécurité pour
l'entreprise et non plus finalement pour
le salariés même si derrière on peut
dire mais ils se sont entendu ça a bien
marché c'est une entreprise
familiale je une Milu agricole on est
sur le même tracteur machin tout ça ça
c'est limite donc du
coup une fois qu'on a dit ça ça n
nécessite en effet d'y donner des
solutions alors les solutions ça
peutêtre en effet le mandatement vous
posiez la question est-ce que c'est
vraiment souhaité par les entreprises
pour les raisons que j'ai cité mais
c'est beaucoup de pédagogie aussi à
faire on ne peut que voir la plusvalue
que ça a d'avoir en face de soi un
interlocuteur qui est accompagné mais je
sais qu'aujourd'hui ça fait peur dans
les petites entreprises d'avoir quelque
part un syndicat qui met sa patte dans
dans dans les affaires de de la petite
TPE qui marche par la bonne volonté des
des uns et des autres maintenant il y a
aussi une autre réponse que prévoit le
le le le le projet de loi qu'on examine
actuellement c'est l'accord type et
encore une fois le rôle des branches
aujourd'hui les branches ont la
possibilité dans leurs différents
accords de prévoir des dispositions
spécifiques à destination des TPE via
des accordtypes que le chef d'entreprise
va pouvoir reprendre à son compte c'est
une solution qui est prévu par le texte
et on est dans le cadre du rôle de de la
branche puisque c'est la branche qui
fixe le cadre et qui donne des outils on
est vraiment dans dans la mission de
service vis-à-vis des TPE qui donne des
outils au TPE pour pouvoir justement
éventuellement adapter un un certain
nombre de modalité à son contexte
d'entreprise donc l'accordtype est aussi
une réponse euh nous pensons à la
question que vous avez
posé ça me permet de faire le lien vers
la branche vous avez posé la la question
des commissions paritaires
permanentes nous c'est quelque chose
qu'on appelle de noveau depuis déjà bien
longtemps ce type de structure et on va
même plus loin et on invite à aller plus
loin en effet renforcer justement ces
commissions paritaires permanente pour
nous les lois au roues qui ont donné la
personnalité morale par exemple au
comité d'entreprise aurait dû aller
jusqu'au bout de la chaîne en donnant
une personne alité morale au branch et
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de dire via ces
commissions paritaires permanentes on a
l'occasion de donner une personnalité
morale à ces comités qui dit
personnalité morale dit adresse
téléphone et donc un
interlocuteur de la
branche légitime qui est
constitué je je je travaille avec la DGT
sur la rest la restructuration des
branches et ainsi de suite et se pose
toujours la question mais on ne sait pas
for quand on veut s'adresser à une
branche on sait pas à qui s'adresser
donc on s'adresse à une une organisation
patronale si on a réussi à l'identifier
c'est pas toujours évident dans
certaines branches d'ailleurs là
aujourd'hui en disant on met en place
ces comités ces commissions paréires de
branch on leur donne et là je vous
invite justement à aller plus loin sur
cction on leur donne cette personnalité
morale chaque
branche sera doté d'un interlocuteur
vous soullignez que certaines
branches ne sont toujours ne sont pas
toujours dotés de de
commission d'interprétation pour le
suivi des des des accords en entreprise
ou alors ça fonctionne pas toujours il
poser la question est-ce qu'il faudrait
pas dans le texte plus plutôt que de
dire que ces commissions s une fois par
an elle devrait se réunir plusieurs fois
étant donné que maintenant on est plus
uniquement sur la commission
d'interprétation mais qu'on est sur la
commission de négociation et
d'interprétation je pense qu'il a même
pas besoin de le prévoir dans le texte
naturellement une branche qui fonctionne
correctement et demain ce sera le cas
suite à la restructuration des branches
qui est engagé demain l'idée c'est de
d'avoir des des branches pour pouvoir
qu' pour pouvoir qu'elle soit validée
qu' puisse perdurer il va falloir
qu'elle mette en place ses commissions
et qu'on on va devoir suivre aussi la la
qualité de travail de la branche des
accords de la diversité des accords qui
qui négocient et ainsi de suite donc
tout ça va dans m'amène à dire pas
forcément besoin de faire un amendement
pour dire fixons à TR qu réunions dans
la branche naturellement les choses se
feront dès lors qu'on renforce qu'on met
en place cette commission de négociation
et d'interprétation et qu'on la renforce
encore plus certains proposaient de
donner encore des
missions complémentaires y compris de
service public visà-vis des TPE je crois
qu'il y a des choses qui sont déjà prévu
on peut en effet aller plus loin et ça
va dans le sens du courrier paritaire
d'ailleurs signé par par tous de de
donner un certain nombre aussi de de
rôles et de mission à la branche euh
donc voilà donc à cette question carence
de certaines branches nous on répond
d'une
part
restructuration qui doit et puis
renforcement d'autre part renforcement
donc mise en place et renforcement des
commissions par paritaire
permanente
concernant concernant concernant le CPA
alors le CPA vous nous dites c'est un
regroupement trois comptes en effet ça a
été soulevé je crois par ma par la
collègue de de de la CFDT
entre autres demandes et entre autres
abonnement qu'on formule nous on demande
justement à ce qu'il y ait une
fongibilité entre ces comptes pour
vraiment rendre ce compte beaucoup plus
opérationnel et faciliter les
transitions professionnelles les
mobilités et ainsi de suite donc nous on
est on est vraiment
demandeur ça c'est un l'objet d'un amend
que l'on formule à mettre en place ce
principe de fongibilité
entre les comptes qui constituent le le
le
CPA on se félicite aussi d'ailleurs de
l'élargissement du CPA de 16 ans à au
décès vous l'avez évoqué c'était une de
nos demandes donc on se félicite de
ça on
partage le l'idée de statut d'actif
plutôt que que de travailleurs euh puis
qui qui a qui est du coup beaucoup plus
large par rapport à cette notion de de
CPA et donc nous notre volonté et je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure dans mes propos
c'est de faire évoluer ce CPA par la
négociation le cadre fixé par la loi
derrière la négociation doit permettre
justement de faire évoluer ce CPA pour
répondre à vos préoccupation sur la
question euh des
retraités euh des nouveaux droits droit
attaché à la personne plutôt qu'au
contrat de travail et ainsi de suite
donc on sera très engagé de toute façon
dans cette négociation nous ltions déjà
ça a donné le résultat qu'on connaît on
continuera très actif pour faire évoluer
ce compte sur sur le compte engagement
citoyen vous dites que le cadre n'est
pas très précis bon il nous semble que
un certain nombre de de dispositifs sont
quand même clairement cités sur la
question de l'engagement associatif
est-ce qu'il faut le préciser plus je ne
sais pas la question reste ouverte j'ai
pas trop d'avis sur sur la question sur
sur le C3P alors ça c'est c'est un gros
sujet beaucoup disent le C3P en
particulier dans un contexte de de TPE
c'est inapplicable B donacte
donacte prenons ce constat en compte
essayant de le faire évoluer en tout cas
la pénibilité c'est un vieux sujet qui
est débattu depuis j'ai envie de dire
des décennies et pour lesquel on n
jamais su trouver de solution
aujourd'hui le C3P mérite d'exister et
de proposer une
solution ça vaut ce que ça vaut si on
constate que c'est pas applicable dans
les entreprises en particulier les TPE
voyons comment on peut l'aménager mais
ne supprimons pas le principe du
traitement de la prévention et du
traitement de la pénbilité qui est un
vrai sujet qui nous préoccupe tous et
pour lequel on a toujours eu des
difficultés jusqu'à jusqu'àaujourd'hui à
le définir définir la pénibilité et à y
trouver des solutions donc s'il faut
aménager le C3P aménageons-le mais
surtout ne supprimons pas le
principe dans les solutions il y a quand
même les référentiels qui peuvent être
négociés au niveau des branche qui offre
quand même une solution en terme
d'outils y compris vis-à-vis des
TPE
euh je pense avoir fait le tour sur la
question du CPA sur l'apprentissage je
redis exactement ce qu'on déjà dit les
collègues c'est évidemment une une vraie
un vrai sujet que nous partageons tous
collectivement parce que c'est un vrai
tremplin vers l'emploi vers l'emploi
qualifié vers l'emploi péren on y croit
maintenant il faut aussi reconnaître de
manière très pragmatique qu'il existe
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de freins
au développement de
l'apprentissage il faut pas faire de
démagogie il faut regarder ses freins et
voir comment on peut y donner des
réponses si on rentre dans la
caricature je vais vous donner un
exemple je du milieu agricole un moment
il était pas possible pour un apprenti
de monter sur un
escabo pas possible de de de de conduire
un engin quoi que ce soit je suis
apprenti la définition d'apprenti c'est
quoi c'est apprendre un métier comment
voulez-vous que j'apprenne un métier si
je peux rien faire des activités de mon
entreprise il s'agit pas de rentrer
dans il faut un cadre évidemment pour
assurer la sécurité et la santé des des
des apprentis mais il faut pas non plus
les empêcher d'exercer
l'activité pour laquelle ils sont censés
apprendre vous voyez donc il y a ce
genre de frein
oou très objectivement il faut se
pencher il faut donner des des réponses
mais en tout cas en effet nous sommes
très attachés au dispositif
d'apprentissage et nous sommes très
engagés sur cette questionl et donc
on j'ai pas envie de dire on répond à
votre demande de nous impliquer en la
matière puisque on est déjà de toute
façon impliqué en la
matière voilà pour cette audition des
sndicat qui s'est tenu hier au Sénat
alors qu'aujourd'hui a encore lieu une
nouvelle journée de manifestation de
contestation du projet de loi travail la
semaine prochaine et bien les auditions
se poursuivent et la commission des
affaires sociales entendra notamment le
patronat avec la CGPME mais aussi le
meddeef vous pouvez toujours voir et
revoir toutes les audition sur notre
site
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire cet après-midi
à 15h pour Sénat 360 présenté par
Delphine Girard très bonne journée sur
les chaînes
parlementaires